[Musique]
bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
sur public sénat les auditions la séance
se poursuivre au sénat place matin
l'audition de jacques toubon le
défenseur des droits qui s'exprime
aujourd'hui devant les sénateurs de la
commission des lois commission présidée
par philippe bas philippe bas qui
préside également le comité de suivi de
l'état d'urgence sanitaire
ce comité de suivi il enchaîne les
auditions depuis le début du confinement
il a notamment entendu la garde des
sceaux nicole belloubet mais aussi le
président du conseil scientifique jean
françois delfraissy ou encore la
présidente de la cnil marie-laure denis
avec l'audition de jacques toubon
aujourd'hui les sénateurs s'intéresse à
la question du respect des droits
la question du respect des libertés
noter que le défenseur des droits s'est
dernièrement inquiétées du creusement
des inégalités dans cette phase du
confinement entre fracture numérique
fracture sociale
il craint aussi des inégalités lors du
déconfinement pour lui par exemple
impossible de ne pas des confiner les
personnes âgées ou malades en même temps
que l'ensemble de la population ce
serait pour lui une discrimination
inacceptable tout de suite donc place à
cette audition qui se tient aujourd'hui
en visioconférence d'une restriction
considérable du droit de visite et qui
fait que cette coupure a à la fois des
inconvénients bien entendu pour les
familles qui ont récupéré les les
enfants passaient mais aussi beaucoup
pour les enfants eux mêmes
d'autant plus que d'autant plus que la
justice des mineurs à des difficultés et
on retombe sur le sujet qu'on aurait
peut-être pu évoquer ce matin s'il n'y
avait pas la crise cher président mais
il y a des difficultés entre
voilà cette audition dont qui est en
cours actuellement à l'audition de
jacques toubon le défenseur des droits
qui s'exprime donc dans le cadre des
auditions que fait le comité de suivi de
l'état d'urgence sanitaire
comité qui essuient qui est donc présidé
par le sénateur philippe bas le
président l ère de la commission des
lois tout de suite donc on va prendre la
direction de cette audition qui a débuté
il ya une demi heure ce matin via mes
chers collègues joue gros cette séance
de la commission des lois
je voudrais accueillir par cette
visioconférence
jacques toubon les défenseurs des droits
que de salut que je remercie de nous
consacrer une partie de sa matinée aux
travaux devront impérativement de se
décider mais je vous le signale se
terminer à 10h40
nous avions prévu depuis longtemps
d'ailleurs d'auditionner jacques toubon
à cette même date avant même le début du
confinement mais sur un autre sujet que
celui qui va occuper nos travaux ce
matin puisque il s'agissait alors de
discuter avec lui de l'ordonnancé sur la
justice des mineurs
elle pas d'être de sujets a perdu de son
importance mais y en a un autre qui a
fait irruption
c'est la loi d'urgence sanitaire ainsi
que le corps de d'ordonnancés et de
décrets pris pour son application et
dont il est évident que ils restreignent
un certain nombre de libertés et nous
avons c'est d'ailleurs le travail que
nous faisons aussi avec le point de vue
qui est celui du parlement de la
commission des lois du sénat
nous avons un vérifier que les mesures
prises dans le cadre de l'état d'urgence
sanitaire sont à la fois nécessaire et
proportionné et
quel donc n'atteignent l'exercice des
libertés que strictement en tant que de
besoin
nous travaillons la commission des lois
au sein d'un comité de suivi ne
procédons comme ce matin des auditions
teignait d'avant déjà produit un premier
rapport depuis 210 pages une semaine
après l'entrée en vigueur de l'état
d'urgence sanitaire et nous poursuivons
nos travaux par de très nombreuses de
l'audition alors je vais donner
immédiatement la parole à jacques toubon
qui s'il le veut bien nous présentera
les gants de réflexion du défenseur des
droits sur la mise en oeuvre de l'état
d'urgence sanitaire
et puis ensuite nous pourrons lui posais
un certain nombre de questions
je rappelle à l'ensemble des collègues
que ils doivent à ce stade de l'audition
de jacques turon couffé leur micro coupé
la caméra je me permettent de dire à
vampire sûr que il est toujours à l'état
et donc il n'a pas réussit pour la
strate correspondants ne mène que david
baigner alors cher jacques toubon
vous avez la parole sharefile bachère
président de la commission des lois et
en l'occurrence du comité de suivi de
l'état d'urgence sanitaire est cher
sénatrices et sénateurs
d'abord je voudrais remercier votre
comité de suivi d'avoir pris le soin de
m'inviter à faire part de notre
expérience puisque ça qu'il s'agit
sur ces deux mois et demi ils ont deux
situations exceptionnelles qui est la
mise en oeuvre de l'état d'urgence
sanitaire et de manière plus générale le
fonctionnement dans notre pays des
services publics
d'abord le nôtre je dis simplement un
mot nous avons le défenseur des droits
mis en place un plan de continuité de
service qui est caractérisée par le
confinement
naturellement ce matin
exceptionnellement par exemple je suis
dans
oh pour participer à cette
visioconférence mais de manière générale
nous pratiquons le confinement le
télétravail ce qui nous a été facilitée
par le fait que depuis maintenant près
de trois ans nous avions beaucoup
développer le télétravail dans notre
maison
sur le plan local ce qui intéresse
beaucoup les élus naturellement locaux
nos permanences de délégués territoriaux
sont fermés tout simplement parce que la
plupart du temps ceux qui détiennent ces
locaux les maisons de justice et du
droit où les antennes locales
municipales et préfectorales sont
actuellement fermés mais mais nous
continuerons à le défenseur des droits
continue naturellement à travailler
d'une part tous les juristes en
télétravail
d'autre part nous avons une permanence
téléphonique qui a accru ses moyens nous
avons même créé un numéro spécial pour
les détenus
tous les délégués territoriaux reste à
disposition pour résumer nous avons à
peu près une activité c'est à dire un
nombre de réclamations de demandes qui
nous est adressé qui est de moitié de ce
qu'elle était à la même époque l'année
dernière
non seulement donc nous avons mis en
place une organisation adaptée mais nous
avons fait évoluer nos méthodes parce
que en fait nous avons à faire dans
beaucoup de cas à des situations
d'urgence qui sont liées à la pandémie
et donc nous traitons désormais autant
ce que j'appellerais des signalements
qui soit collectif ou individuel que des
réclamations
nous continuerons naturellement à
instruire tous les autres dossiers que
nous avons et je signe notamment
physiquement électroniquement beaucoup
de 2,2 de courrier sur des affaires que
nous continuons emmené en contrat
victoire et qui était qui sont
indépendantes de l'état d'urgence
sanitaire
nous employons naturellement beaucoup la
méthode de la saisine des pouvoirs
publics notamment des ministères nous
prenons comme vous l'avez vu un certain
nombre de positions publiques et
finalement
urgence nous avons beaucoup développée
et nous multiplions ce que j'appellerais
des médiations que vous les
parlementaires appellent auriez
interventions mais que naturellement
nous font donc toujours sur une base de
droit et nous avons des contacts
rapprochés j'ai par exemple la semaine
dernière tenue une audioconférence avec
le secrétaire d'état chargé de l'enfance
monsieur taquet que vous avez reçu que
que ceux qui travaillent sur des sujets
qui concernent notamment beaucoup les
les départements et puis nous j'ai eu
aussi une audioconférence avec monsieur
de normandie sur la situation des sans
abri et de l'hébergement d'urgence
donc le défenseur des droits pendant
cette période continuer à exercer sa
double vocation que vous connaissez bien
puisque c'est vous qui l'avez fixé
lorsque vous avez voté la loi organique
de 2011
sa vocation de vigie des droits et des
libertés fondamentales et sa vocation
d'accès au droit est notamment d'assurer
l'égalité dans l'accès aux droits
e je pourrais je vais essayer de vous
dire d'abord une petite synthèse de ce
qu'on est et nos activités et qui je
pense traduit assez bien des les
problématiques qui assaillent les
français et puis notamment je vous dirai
ce que notre réseau territorial à
remonter en ce qui concerne la je dirais
la la la la synthèse de nos de nos
activités nous avons bien entendu pris
position je le ferai tout à l'heure en
parlant de deux ou trois sujets
notamment liés ou déconfinement nous
sommes et forte de 2 de tenir le langage
de l'équilibré degrés entre et de la
conciliation entre les exigences de la
liberté de l'égalité et de la sécurité
trepier fondamentale en l'occurrence en
ces circonstances comme toujours
et puis nous avons travaillé beaucoup au
profit des personnes vulnérables et ça a
été le cas en particulier lorsque
nous sommes préoccupés de savoir comment
les plus vulnérables majeurs protégés
personnes handicapées aveugle pourrez
accéder ou utiliser des attestations
dérogatoire vous savez que de ce point
de vue depuis trois semaines et il ya eu
des progrès importants qui ont été faits
par l'administration par exemple les
aveugles non plus n'ont pas besoin de
produire une attestation nous sommes
efforcés également de traiter les
questions des personnes sans domicile
j'en parlais tout à l'heure à propos du
ministre de normandie nous avons aussi
évoqué les questions de l'accès aux
soins
une question qui a fait l'objet de
médiatisation et qui est extrêmement
importante
nous avons rappelé qu'il était interdit
d'empêcher de payer en espèces et que
les personnes qui n'ont donc pas de
compte bancaire les personnes qui n'ont
pas de carte notamment par exemple les
majeurs incapables peuvent payer avec
des espèces nous avons rappelé qu'elle
était la loi dans ce domaine vous
connaissez la référence des textes je ne
l'aï pas mais il est clair que il y
avait au début
au début il ya eu quelques dérives de
commerçants qui exigeaient le paiement
en carte ce qui naturellement empêché un
certain nombre de gens d'accéder à leurs
besoins élémentaires et notamment à
leurs besoins alimentaires
nous avons de la même façon pour un
certain nombre de publics ou de
personnes en situation difficile nous
avons eu une et je pense que beaucoup
d'élus ont eu également la même
situation à traiter c'est au début du
mois d'avril quand c'est ouvert le
moment du versement des allocations non
contributive et notamment du rsa on
s'est aperçus à ce moment là que le
réseau notamment le réseau de la poste
qui permet de toucher le rsa en espèces
justement ce
ce réseau s'était considérablement
rétracter un tiers probablement des
bureaux continuer à fonctionner et
depuis quinze jours les choses ont été
ont été corrigés mais on a vu des images
de queue qui n'était naturellement pas
admissible sur ce sur ce sujet sur la
poste nous avons eu beaucoup de saisine
et nous avons travaillé donc comme j'ai
dit à l'heure quand une espèce
d'attitude de médiation avec la
direction générale de de la poste sur
les attestations de déplacement donc
j'ai parlé tout à l'heure je pourrais
éventuellement donner des détails mais
il est clair que c'est une formule qui
est adapté à la majorité des gens mais
qui présente beaucoup de difficultés les
sans abri il a été décidé
plus ou moins par le ministère de
l'intérieur de ne pas verbaliser mais
naturellement il faut faire beaucoup
d'informations et cela se passe aussi
vous le savez ce riff beaucoup du
comportement des forces de sécurité je
le dis nous n'avons pas eu beaucoup de
réclamations jusqu'à maintenant qui
relèverait de notre compétence
déontologie de la sécurité
beaucoup de réclamations au à propos du
comportement de certaines de certains
policiers certains jardins nous n'avons
fait que et prétend que globalement
malgré les grandes difficultés
ils font bien leur travail nous nous
avons vous le savez pris une position
forte à l'égard des questions de
détention et de rétention dès le premier
moment nous avons poussé et la garde des
sceaux et le ministre de l'intérieur que
vous avez entendu à prendre des mesures
pour garantir la sécurité sanitaire
donc le poids santé le droit à la vie
des détenus et des retenues
nous avons pris une position publique
commune c'est une des premières fois
avec la contrôleur général des lieux de
détention à des naseaux et le président
de la commission nationale consultative
des droits de l'homme sur ma fille aux
yeux bleus rue à ce sujet nous avons
particulièrement insisté naturellement
sur la situation des 800 mineurs à peu
près 700 800 mineurs qui sont
aujourd'hui détenus
vous le savez le ministère de la justice
a pris des dispositions aujourd'hui
probablement il y a plus de dix mille
détenus en moins dans les détentions
mais nous avons soulevés à cette
occasion j'aurais peut-être l'occasion
d'en parler si vous m'interrogez sur le
fonctionnement du service public de la
justice
le fonctionnement restreint où quelque
sorte sur cette disposition qui rend
automatique la prolongation de la
détention provisoire et qui nous paraît
un peu contradictoire avec la volonté de
alléger le les effectifs d'alléger la
surpopulation carcérale
nous avons pris une position est encore
très récemment
en ce qui concerne les retenues c'est à
dire les centres de rétention
administrative
vous le savez le conseil d'état en a été
saisi le conseil d'état a décidé que il
n'y avait pas lieu de mettre fin à
l'activité des centres de rétention
administrative est essentiellement parce
que le conseil d'état a considéré que la
situation sanitaire était en quelque
sorte maîtrisée depuis que est
intervenue la décision du conseil d'état
il ya maintenant 15 jours
les choses ont beaucoup évolué d'une
part il y a de moins en moins de
d'expulsion est presque plus et donc on
peut s'interroger sur la légalité d'une
rétention
donc je rappelle qu'elle ça
reste à des personnes qui ont vocation à
être expulsés et qui n'est pas la
rétention n'est pas fait pour être une
détention
elle est une rétention administrative en
vue de préparer une expulsion question
de l'égalité et deuxièmement parce qu'on
sait de la situation sanitaire
le rapport qui a été fait vendredi
dernier par le contrôleur général des
lieux de détention
après visite dans physique dans le
centre du mesnil-amelot et le centre de
vincennes a bien montré qu' il y avait
des cas et il y avait des risques de
contagion
donc j'ai re demandé que ces centres qui
sont aujourd'hui sans objet si j'ose
dire et qui présentent des risques à la
fois bien entendu pour les personnes
retenues mais aussi pour les policiers
ou les agents qui travaillent ou les
associations qui travaillent dans ses
centres de rétention j'ai pris cette
position est à tout le moins que l'on
prenne un certain nombre de deux deux
dispositions qu'ils soient plus
protectrice j'aurai l'occasion peut-être
si si vous m'interrogez d'évoquer plus
largement les mais question du service
public de l'art de la justice je
voudrais simplement souligné que nous
avons été très attentifs à la situation
des enfants
je vais des mineurs non accompagnés mais
des enfants de manière générale ceux qui
sont en particulier placé à l'aide
sociale à l'enfance gelé vous en dire un
mot
dans un instant et jeux pour les enfants
une des questions qui a été plus
médiatisés c'est celle que nous avons
soulevés
lorsque nous sommes aperçus sur des
réclamations qui nous ont été adressées
très nombreuses et de partout en france
et à l'égard de toutes les grandes
enseignes de grande distribution
l'os nous nous sommes aperçus qu'il y
avait cette fameuse mise à l'écart 7
noeuds ce fameux refus de faire entrer
les enfants qui accompagnaient des
parents
maman ou papa qui était seule avec ses
enfants c'est le cas naturellement de
des familles monoparentales et qu'ils ne
pouvaient pas faire leurs courses
autrement qu'en se faisant accompagner
par leurs enfants et vous le savez
beaucoup d'enseignants avaient décidé
que leurs services de sécurité
interdisez aux enfants de d'entrée avec
la mère ou le père qui faisait les
courses et les laisser sur le le parking
avec les caddies globalement globalement
il n'y a pas de l'instruction générale
qui a été donné
les préfets ont agit au coup par coup et
dans le bon sens je crois que
globalement aujourd'hui à l'heure où je
vous parle cette situation et redresser
mais on voit bien comment l'intérêt
supérieur de l'enfant est dans ces
circonstances dramatiques sous l'angle
complètement négligé et j'aurai
l'occasion de dire tout à l'heure un mot
sur la question est ce que scolaire en
ce qui concerne les attestations
dérogatoire je veux simplement dire que
nous avons traité cette question dès le
décret du 16 mars
quand je rappelle que ces attestations
sont antérieurs à la loi de l'état
d'urgence sanitaire du 23 mars
là la difficulté était que les
situations spécifiques comme je l ai dit
à l'heure n'ont pas été prises en compte
et que beaucoup de gens se sont sentis
en quelque sorte discriminés parce qu'il
n'avait pas la possibilité de sortir
condé motif légitime permettant d'avoir
une dérogation parce que ils n'avaient
pas la possibilité de d'accéder à la à
l'autorisation que le fait d'être passé
à l'autorisation numérique présente un
avantage bien entendu mais en même temps
mais en même temps elle pose tout entier
le problème que j'aurais peut-être
l'occasion d'évoquer avec vous qui est
que nous sommes aujourd'hui dans une
injonction paradoxale les nouvelles
technologies nous permettent de
continuer à fonctionner d'abord de
télétravailler ou de tenue
7 mio conférence ensemble monsieur le
président mais en même temps elle écarte
de manière manifeste les millions et des
millions de personnes dont nous avons
expliqué dans notre rapport du 17
janvier 2019 sur ces questions que l été
discriminés écarté en situation illégale
notamment ce qui est notre sujet dans
l'accès aux services publics
lorsque cet axe et se faisait uniquement
ou préférentiellement par voie numérique
et on voit bien que désormais cette
question est en matière de santé en
matière de protection sociale de tous
les gestes de la vie courante
une question essentielle et je pense que
les sénateurs qui ont en particulier le
souci de la couverture du territoire
seront extrêmement attentifs désormais à
cette question notre rôle a été sur
cette attestation de faire en sorte que
le ministère de l'intérieur prenne en
compte les situations des personnes
vulnérables spécifiquement les sans
domicile fixe
donc il y a des possibilités de ne pas
être verbalisé les les possibilités de
s'expliquer nous avons traité la
question des majeurs protégés et
notamment de l'expertisé médicale
et puis nous avons obtenu donc eu des
situations des dispositions
particulières le ministre vers en est la
secrétaire d'état
sophie 7 on en parlait il ya quinze
jours en faveur des personnes
handicapées
de manière générale en ce qui concerne
les prestations jeu je voudrais
souligner quelque chose qui est je pense
que ça intéressera les élus locaux que
vous êtes le la manière dont de nos
délégués dont j'ai expliqué qu'ils ne
tiennent plus de permanence physique
mais eux ont vu arriver là les
difficultés en quelque sorte je voudrais
juste celle thèse kim est remonté il y à
48 heures des principales réclamations
ou signalements ont été reçus par nos
délégués territoriaux sur le terrain
premièrement je les dis les accès des
supermarchés pour les enfants avec leurs
parents
deuxièmement la sphère des difficultés
d'accès aux services bancaires en
général mais la poste en particulier de
deuxième troisième question la
continuité des services publics et bien
entendu beaucoup de gens se sont plaints
du côté de la question du courrier
toutes les questions qui sont liées avec
la dématérialisation
il est clair que healy
qu'est-ce qui a privilégié l'accès
numérique avec tous les risques
d'exclusion une discrimination dont je
parlais
bien mes chers collègues je m'aperçois
que monsieur jacques toubon n'est plus
avec nous je pense que il va pouvoir se
reconnecter dans un instant vous demande
donc un tout petit peu de patience
le voici sur défenseur des droits vous
êtes de nouveau un écran vous pouvez
donc poursuivre votre propre horaire
est-ce que j'ai été coupé
oui oui alors je reprends donc j'étais
en train de parler des questions de
verbalisation et je parlais de cette
maman d'un enfant autiste auquel on
avait verbalisé parce que elle avait
dépassé l'heure fatidique où elle devait
sortir pour des activités physiques et
ici nous avons fait notre travail de
2009 nous avons sont remontés le
personnes à l'étranger qui souhaitait
revenir en france je pense que les
sénateurs représentant les français de
l'étranger ont été très actif aussi dans
ce domaine nous avons eu des problèmes
avec les étudiants d'outre-mer les
enfants je vais en dire un mot et dont
les mineurs non accompagnés
ça c'est un peu le résumé de ce que nos
délégués ont remonté en ce qui concerne
les enfants
il ya d'une part actuellement la
situation générale de tous les enfants
et je vais en parler à propos de
l'éducation
mais il y a aussi les enfants qui sont
confiés à l'aide sociale à l'enfance et
qui sont pour la moins 330 milles où 340
milles dont la moitié d'entre eux à peu
près sont placés soit dans des foyers
dans des établissements soit dans des
familles d'accueil et je le dis aux
sénateurs et sénatrices on a retrouvé
dans beaucoup des questions qui ont été
posées des échos des débats qui ont eu
lieu au sénat à l'assemblée
mais au sénat spécifiquement en 2015 et
lorsqu'a été examiné la proposition de
loi qui avait été présenté par madame
et qui est devenue la loi de mars 2016
c'est à dire la nouvelle loi sur la
protection sociale de l'enfance on voit
bien on voit bien que il existe un vrai
problème de coordination
un vrai problème deux des acteurs sur le
terrain
un vrai problème de pilotage national de
l'aide sociale à l'enfance
et là les représentants des départements
qui sont dans votre assemblée savent
naturellement de quoi je je je parle le
119 doit être absolument soutenu
davantage qu'il ne l'a été
nous avons réclamé une plateforme de
ressources à destination des parents
parce que la caractéristique bien
entendu de la situation c'est qu'il ya
eu le retour des enfants à peu près
systématique dans leurs familles
accompagnées d'une restriction
considérable du droit de visite et qui
fait que cette coupure a à la fois des
inconvénients bien entendu pour les
familles qui ont récupéré les les
enfants passaient mais aussi beaucoup
pour les enfants eux eux mêmes d'autant
plus que d'autant plus que la justice
des mineurs à des difficultés et on
retombe sur le sujet qu'on aurait
peut-être pu évoquer ce matin s'il n'y
avait pas la crise cher président mais
il y a des difficultés entre la justice
des mineurs et les départements il ya
des départements quelque sorte prennent
des décisions sur pour eux partent par
exemple pour supprimer des droits de
visite sans décision du juge
inversement le le juge prenne les
décisions sans audition des parties
et sur ce point je voudrais souligner
parce que un des points qui a été
soulevée après les ordonnances qui ont
été présentés par la garde des sceaux
sur le fonctionnement de la justice
un des points qui a été souligné c'est
celui qui fait que les juges prennent
des décisions
en quelque sorte sans contradictoires il
y à une décision 10 avril du conseil
d'état relative à l'organisation
judiciaire dont j'ai remarqué un une des
dispositions et qui dit ces dispositions
justifiée par l'intérêt qui s'attache à
la continuité du suivi éducatif des
mineurs concernés et qui sait le point
important contrairement à ce qui est
soutenu
soutenu par le gouvernement ne font pas
obstacle à ce que le mineur capable de
discernement puisse préalablement
exprimé son avis donc le conseil d'état
a validé naturellement les dispositions
de l'ordonnancé mais il a bien souligné
que néanmoins il fallait faire effort
pour que les décisions des juges soient
prises en particulier après consultation
de démineurs ce bien sûr nous avons eu à
traiter la situation
dmn a sur ce point il y à un certain
nombre de départements et où le service
en quelque sorte d'accueil d'évaluation
et demi de la bri a tout simplement
fermé c'est le cas à paris particuliers
et/ou ensuite nous nous sommes retrouvés
avec des mineurs non accompagnés qui ont
lieu d'être traités comme des enfants
comme des mineurs étaient traités comme
des étrangers ordinaire et la situation
à progresser je crois dans le bon sens
dans beaucoup de départements mais
j'appelle la tension du sénat sur ce
sujet il y a le le le il y à dent donc
puis ça bien entendu vous le savez tous
et je pense que les leçons devant être
tirées
il y a donc tous à des considérations
sociales et des considérations de
d'inégalités sociales très fortes mais
je lisais une déclaration d'un
parlementaire jaupart récemment qui a
dit une phrase je trouve très forte
le confinement renvoie les enfants à la
brutalité des différences de classes et
c'est pour ça monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs que un des points
très importants et je fais la une
transition avec le déconfinement un des
points très importants que je voudrais
souligner c'est combien la disparition
de la restauration collective est un des
éléments centraux de ces disparités
sociales et de ce décrochage social et
éducatif que le ministre de l'éducation
nationale et le gouvernement ont
naturellement pris en compte et qui les
conduit notamment à vouloir réouvrir le
les établissements scolaires à tous les
niveaux à partir du 11 mai mais jeudi
aux sénateurs et sénatrices nous avons
eu beaucoup de débats sur ce sujet à
plusieurs reprises que la cantine nous
l'avons écrit dans beaucoup de rapport
doit être considérée comme un service
essentiel
un service essentiel à la réalisation
des droits à l'éducation bien entendu
mais aussi dans la circonstances
actuelles un service essentiel pour que
peut-être des centaines de milliers
d'enfants ne soit pas dans un certain
nombre de départements laissés pour
compte et tout simplement renvoyé à une
nourriture très insuffisante
certains ont commencé à parler de la
faim dans certains départements et je le
dis
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs il
existe à mon avis des possibilités
notamment en s'adressant à tous les
concessionnaires de la restauration
collective qui aujourd'hui n'ont plus à
traiter leurs commanditaires dans les
entreprises privées
à c
fournisseur de la restauration
collective inventons des solutions pour
que des centaines de milliers d'enfants
qu'ils soient scolarisés ou qu'il ne le
soit pas aujourd'hui puissent accéder
dans de bonnes conditions à une
nourriture qui ne peut pas
convenablement leur est donnée dans leur
famille
je viens de parler des enfants je
voudrais naturellement ne pas oublier
monsieur le président que nous avons
beaucoup
on en a parlé beaucoup et souvent dans
des conditions dramatiques
je ne voudrais pas en rajouter mais les
personnes âgées
bien sûr j'ai pris connaissance avec
beaucoup d'attention du rapport de
jérôme guedj de la de la recommandation
qui a été fait très récemment le 20
avril et après le rapport guedj qui
s'appelle le protocole relatif aux
consignes applicable dans les
établissements médico-sociaux et l'unité
de soins de longue durée c'est-à-dire
cette instruction dans lequel à la suite
de la décision du gouvernement
on a permis de nouveau le contact entre
les personnes hébergées dans les
établissements et leurs familles et
c'est une question qui m a paru
suffisamment importante pour que
vendredi
je vais réunir ce que j'appelle le
comité d'entente avancée en âge
c'est-à-dire par audio ou
visioconférence
nous allons nous réunir avec les
représentants d'une quinzaine
d'associations et nous avons nous allons
examiner cette question dans le dans le
détail comme nous l'aurions fait
actuellement dans les temps ordinaire je
termine mon seul président en dix ans
quelques mots plus prospectif de ce que
sont les exigences que nous
souhaiterions voir respecter pour le
déconfinement pour le déconfinement tout
propos
sion de prolonger le confinement d'une
partie de la population en fonction de
l'âge ou de l'état de santé ce qui avait
été évoqué il y a quelques jours on
serait naturellement des risques de
discrimination et donc quelques
principes et points de vigilance doivent
être rappelés l'âge et l'état de santé
vous le savez sont dans la loi de 2008
des critères protégés par la loi et par
le droit européen en matière de
discrimination la discrimination qui est
prohibé consiste à traiter différemment
sans justification objective et
raisonnable des personnes qui sont
plates et tombe à des situations
analogues ont comparables une mesure
serait considérée comme discriminatoire
si elle ne poursuit pas je mets entre
guillemets un but ou un objectif
légitime où je vais aussi entre
guillemets s'il n'y a pas de rapports
raisonnable de proportionnalité entre
les moyens employés et le but visé plus
la pinte mettra en cause un droit de
valeurs essentielles plus exigeantes
d'intentionnalité sera strict et donc
sur les éventuelles mesures de maintien
du confinement à l'égard d'une partie de
la population
il faudra d'une part en démontrer
là il faudra que les autorités en
démontre la nécessité et l'âge n'est pas
le seul critère à prendre en compte
comme le haut comité d'ailleurs la santé
publique l'a dit en listant les
personnes à risque de développer une
forme grave d'infection au ce1 ce2 et en
particulier les personnes souffrant de
co morbidités le l'union européenne
d'ailleurs dans sa feuille de route du
15 avril a recommandé aux états de
protéger pour les personnes pour une
période plus longue mais elle n'a pas
dit comment il fallait faire la prise de
position de la commission d'ailleurs a
été controversée par certains la mesure
doit être nécessaire elle nous
or et proportionnée que s'il était
démontré qu'il n'existe aucune autre
mesure alternative - attentatoires aux
droits et aux libertés de la personne
qui permettrait d'atteindre l'objectif
recherché et les jurisprudences
européennes que sochaux celle de la cour
de strasbourg ou celle de la cour de
luxembourg disent qu'il convient de
recourir à la moins contraignante des
mesures appropriées et que les
inconvénients causés ne doivent pas être
des mesures et par rapport aux objectifs
visés ainsi la conclusion c'est qu'une
mesure générale systématique devrait
être écarté et nous avons l'impression
d'après les dernières déclarations
publiques y compris du président public
que c'est bien la position qui a été
prise par le gouvernement
en conclusion sur le décompte ces
mesures qui consistent à poursuivre le
confinement pour un certain nombre de
personnes se sait cette mesure ne
devrait être envisagée que dans des
conditions très strictes
avec une durée limitée sans que cela
puisse être une mesure de portée
générale sont à reposer comme il a été
dit d'ailleurs non pas sur une
obligation mais sur la responsabilité
individuelle
s'il y avait une obligation monsieur le
président nous considérons pour notre
part que il conviendrait d'adopter une
nouvelle disposition législative
complétant la loi
état d'urgence sanitaire et qui
prévoirait un avis médical de manière à
assurer l'équilibré entre l'intérêt
général de la sécurité sanitaire et le
risque de discrimination
le placement en quarantaine ou en
isolement sont parmi ces mesures des
mesures qu'ils sont prévues dans la loi
du 23 mars
c'est l'article 31 31 15 du code de la
santé publique
ces mesures selon la loi doivent être
strictement proportionnées au riz
ce que sanitaires encourus et appropriée
aux circonstances de temps et de lieu et
la loi dit qu'il y ait mis fin sans
délai lorsqu'elles ne sont plus
nécessaires car ces mesures sont
naturellement des mesures qui peuvent
être non pas des mesures restrictives de
liberté mais des mesures privatives de
liberté et vous avez eu récemment une
dernière décision du conseil fonctionnel
où on voit bien que la question de
l'application de l'article 66 de la
constitution c'est-à-dire de la
compétence des juridictions judiciaires
a été posée nous sommes donc très
attentif à tout ce qui a été à tout ce
qui pourrait être fait dans ce domaine
il y a d'ailleurs tout un corpus qui est
la jurisprudence force et non peut être
fait dans certaines conditions les états
du conseil de l'europe ont adoptées et
notamment avec notre le concours notre
délégation parlementaire le 7 avril
dernier un texte qui s'appelle respecter
la démocratie l'état de droit et les
droits de l'homme dans le cadre de la
crise sanitaire du coc vide
19 et naturellement il ya toujours la
possibilité de saisir un juge
je dirais simplement un mot mais il a
été beaucoup parler monsieur le
président puisque vous avez reçu tout
dernièrement le secrétaire d'état
compétents que ceux capables état au
numérique
monsieur ses briques ou sur le sujet de
la fameuse application stop qu'ovide la
semaine prochaine le l'assemblée
nationale et le sénat en débattrons
voteront d'après ce que j'ai compris sur
cette mesure moi je pense que j'ai été
le premier il ya quinze jours ou trois
semaines a rappelé l'attention sur ces
questions et sur les difficultés
qu'elles peuvent naturellement
introduire pour nos libertés et la vie
privée les
textes européens sont assez claires la
cnil après un rapport 2 avril dernier
c'est mystique le comité des titres
numériques du conseil consultatif
national d'éthique avait pris position
quelques jours avant dans le même sens
le conseil national du numérique a été
saisie par le gouvernement comme lorsque
cédric on vous l'a dit il y a que
quelques jours je pense que ils auront
des avis et touche tout autour il vous
plaît en disant qu' il est droit je
voudrais juste indiquer à celui de notre
collègue qui la donnent micro est
branché et qui est en train d'utiliser
le clavier d'un ordinateur que tout le
monde entend le clavier fonctionne et ce
qui perturbe la bonne audition du propos
du défenseur des droits
et vous avez la parole monsieur
défenseur des droits merci monsieur
président et je termine simplement pour
dire que sur cette affaire dont j'ai
souligné la norme difficulté
naturellement parce que bien sûr elle
peut présager l'idée d'un service de 2,2
d'un système de surveillance sociale
générale vous avez tous vous êtes tous
au courant du système qu'on appelle le
crédit social en chine mais il ya
d'autres pays où il ya d'autres exemples
nous avons là naturellement la nécessité
que ces mesures soient sur la base du
volontariat que les données qui sont
recueillies ne remonte pas dans une base
centrale que ces données soient très
clairement supprimés à la fin des
circonstances qui conduisent à mettre en
oeuvre cette application et que tout
ceci naturellement doit faire l'objet
d'un grand dispositif d'information car
il ne faudrait pas que soit le public
rejette ce type de mesure qui peut être
utile il faut le démontrer
soit au contraire il y adhèrent à
beugler mans parc
par crainte par peur de la pandémie sans
connaissance de cause et vous savez très
bien que c'est ce que nous avons
toujours dit c'est qu'on sait nouvelles
technologies la connaissance est un
élément nécessaire indépendamment de la
technique pour l'accès aux droits
voilà monsieur le président je je je
m'en tiendrai là dans cette première
intervention pour pouvoir répondre à vos
questions sur un certain nombre de
sujets mais je voudrais simplement dire
que mon expérience et et celle de des
parlementaires qui sont en face de moi
ou autour de moi virtuellement en moins
de cinq ans notre pays puisque c'est
depuis novembre 2015
notre pays a connu deux épisodes d'état
d'urgence pour affronter deux menaces et
deux attaques meurtrières de nature
complètement différentes mais qui s'en
prenaient à nos sociétés et à nos
personnes l'état d'urgence anti
terroriste et l'état d'urgence sanitaire
par lesquelles nous sommes aujourd'hui
le trépied dont j'ai parlé tout à
l'heure monsieur le président liberté
égalité ça curie sécurité l'equilibre ce
trépied est en cause et je voudrais ici
revenir par exemple on rapport qui a été
fait en février 2018 par le crédoc qui
est le centre de recherches et d'études
sur les droits fondamentaux
l'université de nanterre et d'autres
rapports qui a été fait avec le concours
de défenseur des droits
février 2018 et qui était intitulé ce
qui restera toujours de l'état d'urgence
état d'urgence anti terroriste de 2015
et dans ce rapport il est dit c'est sur
la
entre alité même des droits et des
libertés dans nos ordres juridiques et
politiques qu une expérience comme celle
de l'état d'urgence nous invite à
réfléchir bien monsieur le président si
je voulais pour conclure pour terminer
mon propos en tant que défenseur des
droits j'ai réfléchi je continue à le
faire aujourd'hui devant vous le 17
juillet je quitterai mes fonctions de
défenseur des droits
la commission des lois elle du sénat
sera éternelle et elle continuera à
travailler en particulier ce comité de
suivi de l'état d'urgence sanitaire
je te dirais que j'aurais beaucoup aimé
être commissaire aux lois au luxembourg
au palais du luxembourg pour contribuer
à ce travail auquel de réflexion auquel
je vous invite sur centralité ou non des
droits et libertés dans nos jours de
juridiques et politiques
en tout cas dans l'immédiat je vous
souhaite bon travail et j'espère que le
défenseur des droits
ici comme dans d'autres circonstances
aura pu y contribuer merci beaucoup
monsieur de défenseur des droits je
devrais dire ce serait pour nous un très
grand honneur que nous rejoindre après
mandat de défenseurs des fois et j'ai un
se souviennent de l'expérience que vous
avez comme président de la commission
des lois de l'assemblée nationale il ya
quelques années je voudrais vous dire à
quel point j'ai été intéressé par votre
exposé qui a permis de couvrir un large
champ de l'application de l'état
d'urgence sanitaire de l'activité des
services de police dont vous avez dit
qu'ils avaient suscitées qu'elle avait
suscité peu de contester
sion à ce stade c'est une bonne chose au
lieu de rétention de liberté pour lequel
vous avez soulevé en revanche un certain
nombre de difficultés
puis en passant par la situation
particulière des enfants dans lequel
vous y êtes attentifs à juste titre et
nous le sommes aussi vous avez évoqué
également la situation des personnes
âgées et handicapées
puis les exigences du déconfinement en
soulignant que toute différence de
traitement entre des catégories de
personnes devait être strictement
justifiée et proportionnée à la
nécessité de protéger ces personnes et à
travers elle le reste de la société
bien sûr je vous remercie également
d'avoir dit un mot d'applications
stop&go vide dont on comprend que vous
avez réfléchi aux conditions qui
permettraient qu'elle se développe dans
le respect de la vie privée de chaque
quart avec un certain nombre de
paramètres aurait dans ce cas respecté
merci donc pour cet exposé d'ensemble je
voudrais maintenant vous proposer de
donner la parole à l'ensemble des
collègues qui se sont inscrits pour
pouvoir faire des observations ou vous
poser des questions
nous fonctionnons en nous donnant
progressivement à la visioconférence ans
en général elle fonctionne dans de
bonnes conditions
mais pour cela il faut que nous
respections un certain nombre de
disciplines
je vais donc demander aux collègues dont
je vais citer le nom de se préparer à
prendre la parole en leur disant de
nouveau que les actionnent leurs caméras
et leurs micros pour prendre la parole
mais qu'ils veuillent bien dès qu'ils
ont terminée couper leurs micros et
caméras parce que si nous sommes trop
nombreux à occuper l'image et la bande
passante
cela perturbe la qualité de la vision
conférence sur le plan technique
donc je vais maintenant citer les
collègues qui se sont eux
ce cri dans l'ordre comme ça chacun
saura à quel moment il faut qu'ils
s'apprêtent à actionner son micro et sa
caméra
la première es marie pierre de la
gontrie suivi de madame brigitte dernier
suivi de monsieur à la marque suivi de
madame kospi de madame benbassa de
madame mercier et enfin le dernier mot
reviendra pour ces questions à monsieur
le comte obama et pierre de la gontrie
vous avez la parole
merci président je salue tous les tous
les collègues et évidemment le défenseur
des droits vous m'entendez bien oui
moyens derrière je vous salue a fait
manger vous salue également
je voulais vous interroger sur plusieurs
sur plusieurs sujets vous êtes revenu
sur votre prise de position dès le 18
mars et réitéré le 18 avril prochain
dans les centres de rétention
vous avez demandé l'arrêt des placements
et la fermeture notamment du mesnil
amelot
plus généralement et pour avoir
peut-être un échange assez libre comment
appréciez-vous finalement le suivi des
avis qui sont ennemis que vous émettez
puisque en tout cas sur ce point précis
on ne peut pas dire que le gouvernement
ait réellement pris conscience des
choses et se soit rangée à votre
préconisation sachant que la dernière
visite effectivement delà d'un
contrôleur des lieux privatifs de
liberté à kinase ans au mesnil amelot
était assez préoccupante puisque je le
dis qu'au collègue personne n'avait de
masques ni les retenue ni le personnel
puisque il pensait que personne n'avait
de cas la deuxième le deuxième point que
je souhaitais aborder c'est globalement
vous allez parler de l'accès au droit au
pluriel deux points paraissent très
inquiétant je ne sais pas si vous ont
été soumis d'une part la fermeture assez
large des conseils des prud'hommes qui
mène à ce que les salariés en
l'occurrence ne puissent même pas faire
de procédure via un référé pour réclamer
le paiement d'un salaire
mais également la fermeture assez large
pour ne pas dire total des guichets de
demandes d'asile qui pose évidemment
d'autres problèmes enfin vous avez parlé
de ce top que vides
j'ai lu avec intérêt l'interview que
vous avez donné un magazine dénommée
désormais l'ops
en date du 30 mars où vous évoquez tous
les points que vous avez évoqué là donc
je n'y reviens pas vous avez une phrase
qui est que je trouve intéressante qui
indiquait qu'il faudrait et je cite
forcément mettre à l'examen un texte qui
ont fixé les règles
donc pensez vous que indépendamment de
l'impérieuse nécessité ou non d'avoir
une législation il faudrait le faire
et enfin j'ai cru voir que vous étiez
membres avec voix consultative de la
cnil
et si je ne me trompe pas pensez-vous
participer à ces échanges qui je crois
devrait se tenir à la cnil
vendredi sur ce point est ce que
monsieur le président elles sont les
deux je préférais pardon monsieur de
défenseur des droits que tous les
collègues puissent vous posez la
question parce que tu as de la
visioconférence c'est la question que je
voulais vous poser
voilà je compte note les questions et je
les accumule merci beaucoup
oui c'est mieux merci beaucoup alors
madame brigitte lherbier
oui bonjour monsieur le président
bonjour monsieur le défenseur des droits
entendez bonjour je vous entends bien
monsieur le défenseur des droits
j'aurais voulu revenir sur la protection
de l'enfant où l'avait évoqué je sais
que ça vous intéresse particulièrement
les violences faites aux femmes pose des
difficultés mais on sait l'évolution se
fait tout le monde en a pris conscience
et je pense que c'est une préoccupation
tant de la police et de l'ensemble de la
population
par contre la protection à la
maltraitance des enfants cause pose
problème les enfants ne peut pas porter
donc c'est simplement les voisins ça
simplement des gens qui appellent au 119
qui peuvent faire réagir qui peuvent
signaler le cas d'un enfant qui a subi
des maltraitances aussi dans notre
période de confinement les services
éducatifs du département ne sont pas au
complet il est trés extrêmement
difficile d'aller au domicile des
parents pour évaluer le danger en par
l'enfant alors ma question justement
tourne autour de ce sujet comment
fait-on le bâtonnier de lille m'a dit
que les juges des enfants les juges des
affaires familiales sont extrêmement
difficiles à joindre
comment faire pour mettre en application
une assistance éducative dans de telles
conditions sachant qu' il est
pratiquement impossible d'aller ou de à
demeure des parents pour évaluer le
danger subies par l'enfant
on a beaucoup de retours de voisins qui
se disent n'avoir eu aucun effet leurs
appels n'avaient pas eu de suite
voilà monsieur le défenseur des droits
c'est une question qui me touche
particulièrement et je sais que vous
aussi merci monstres ou wifi clavier
monsieur alain marc même temps 2 à voilà
le petit bonjour président georges de
savoir si vous d'argent je saisis si
vous avez des saisies par des usagers de
la poste vous avez bouquet dans vos
propos liminaire 1
les bénéficiaires du rsa et nous de la
mort ce qui nous oblige à ces derniers
et à de longues files d'attentes pour
toucher leurs revenus en liquide
sauf qu aussi un milieu très rurale pas
mal de bureau ont reconnu des ouvertures
très difficile public
aujourd'hui les bureaux n'est pas assuré
pour certains de produits population
très isolés
trouvez vous cela normal et avez-vous
saisie judiciaire sur le défenseur car
souvent nos médias se focalisent sur les
problèmes des cités dans les quartiers
difficiles de nos vide mais nos
populations rurales subissent des
difficultés
je ne dirais pas de discrimination en
silence et je trouve cela complètement
anormal
merci merci beaucoup chers collègues de
cette question et donc maintenant la
parole à madame jose il ya une cost
qu'est ce que madame costeux m'entends
madame josiane cost
j'ai peur qu'il ya un problème de
connexion avec madame cost
madame benbassa et elle l'a dit madame
benbassa montant veut-elle bien prendre
le tour de madame coste je reviendrai à
madame cost ensuite sony g 100 g micro
monsieur le monsieur le président un
poste très bien madame benbassa si vous
voulez bien patienter avec madame copie
merci merci madame cost merci monsieur
le président monsieur défenseur des
droits ma question porte sur les mineurs
enfermés ils sont environ 700 dans les
opm et les quartiers pour mineurs et
madame la garde des sceaux nous a
signalé que l'éducation nationale et est
absente ces mineurs là n'ont pas eu
d'école depuis le début du confinement
ça me paraît très préjudiciable pour eux
bien entendu et je voudrais savoir s'ils
ont par contre d'encadrement éducatif
serré et consistant parce que évidemment
les risques sont grands pour ces mineurs
à la sortie qu'il risque évidemment de
ne retomber dans une délinquance total
bien sûr je voudrais savoir également si
tous les mn à son protégé dans des
foyers ou s'il en reste encore présent
dans des hôtels est finalement un peu à
l'abandon et non suivi voilà je vous
remercie monsieur le défenseur des
droits merci beaucoup mieux reconnaît
maintenant la parole et madame à madame
esther benbassa de la parole merci
monsieur le président merci monsieur
toubon pour le moins très exposé et vous
avait déjà parlé du tracking mais je le
souhaitais savoir qu'elle serait reçue
passage dans le traçage utiliserait
seulement vous le voulez bien
quelles seraient les retombées
si cette application était mise en
marche sur nos libertés publiques
bien sûr si on ne prenait pas les plus
les précautions nécessaires pourriez
vous nous donner quelques éléments
supplémentaires
merci merci à vous chers collègues
mercier madame mercier vous avez la
parole merci monsieur le président
monsieur le défenseur des droits bonjour
je voudrais parler des professionnels
des états
nous savons qu'ils rendent un service
absolument considérable on connaît la
difficulté de leur travail auprès des
les enfants classés et qui sont
maintenant confinés dans les
établissements nous savons que des
professionnels n'avaient pas de masque
au début du confinement
ils sont aussi en proie à des
difficultés considérables pour respecter
les gestes porter ça doit être soignée
ça doit même être cajolé en ce moment
les visites des parents sont interdites
bien évidemment il y a dans ses
établissements des ados qui sont
confinés aussi donc avec une forme de
violence qui doit s'exprimer
ces professionnels pallie à une ambiance
morose mais ils doivent aussi pallier à
l'absence de certains de leurs collègues
donc monsieur défenseur des droits je
voudrais vous dire que je suis troublée
pour le double morts au sud cet angle
mort qui existe pour ces professionnels
de santé il faut savoir d'une santé
particulière parce que de leur enfant
n'ait pas pu être accueillis l'éducation
nationale les avait tout simplement
oublié alors que ce sont des
fonctionnaires au même titre que les
soignants donc je voulais savoir s'il
partageait le point de vue est votre
avis concernant la reconnaissance que
l'état aidera à avoir vis-à-vis de ses
fonctionnaires de la fonction publique
hospitalière au même titre que les
soignants je vous remercie
très bien madame merci madame merci à
monsieur le comte
[Musique]
oui bonjour monsieur le consul défenseur
des noms circulent à nouveau entendue
bonjour aux et votre question voilà donc
c'est bien vous j'espère que c'est un
féru nous quelques mots aux polonais de
vérifier mon gars allez y est certes par
un jour jean yves le conte vous pouvez y
aller cher collègue
bon on pourra continuer en colonne est
si vous vérifiez que vous êtes à à
contre jour a lancé ça fait bizarre
oui mais je ne sais pas comment faire
dans vos bureaux maintenant voilà j'ai
quatre questions en fait vous avez
évoqué la situation dans les cra et
lorsque nous avons interrogé le ministre
de l'intérieur nous a dit que les
expulsions se faisait toutefois les
chiffres que moi j'ai reçu sur le mois
d'avril ne font état que d'expulsions à
notre frontière brésilienne et rien
d'autre est ce que vous vous avez des
chiffres plus précis sur des expulsions
au mois deux mois d'avril parce que je
je suis un peu étonné youn encore eu en
mars et en avril bon voilà le problème
c'est que si il n'y a que des choses qui
se passent en guyane ça pose
effectivement un problème sur le sens
des centres de rétention
vous avez évoqué la situation des
français qui rentraient de l'étranger
est ce que vous avez été
particulièrement touchée par des gens
qui vous qui se plaignaient de ne pas
avoir obtenu de remboursement ou qui
n'avaient pas su pas eu la capacité de
d'accéder à l'avion malgré un ticket
acheté sur l'application stop coville
deux questions un peu à côté mais qui
sont liés finalement à cette
problématique
la première est ce que on est vraiment
certain qu'aujourd'hui la génération d
électronique des des attestations
dérogatoire n'engendre pas un suivi
électronique de ceux ci derrière et
deuxièmement au delà de
deux des conséquences de ce top cow vide
est-ce que ce qui est envisagé en termes
de traitement et traçage manuel des
contacts des personnes qui seraient
infectés fait aussi partie des sujets
qui vous qui vous préoccupe
enfin compte tenu de ce que vous avez
évoquées ah la la
à la fin de votre intervention nous
sommes dans une période d'état d'urgence
mais qui n'a rien à voir avec la période
précédente
parce que tant le contrôle de
constitutionnalité que contrôle de
légalité sont très largement atterré par
les difficultés d'accès au droit et aux
avocats
comment comment peut-on finalement quand
même faire valoir l'existence de l'état
de droit dans une telle période
avec finalement un accès aux avocats
particulièrement limitées et une justice
qui est quasiment à l'arrêt je vous
remercie
merci beaucoup chers collègues je
voudrais rebondir sur cette dernière
question parmi les trois que poser jean
yves le conte c'est vrai que nous avons
eu à nous pencher et tout
particulièrement depuis le début de
cette période sur les conditions de
fonctionnement des juridictions aussi
bien de l'ordre judiciaire que de
l'ordre administratif pour assurer la
continuité du service public de la
justice un certain nombre de
dispositions ont été prises elles
restreignent fortement les garanties
offertes revue stable au pire étant pour
nous évidemment plastique fait son arrêt
que vous pouvez plus du tout fonctionné
avec mais il est des personnes que
l'accès au droit est aujourd'hui
particulièrement difficile alors même
que des libertés aussi fondamental que
la liberté d'aller et venir sont
réduites et que les forces de police et
gendarmerie pour faire respecter le
confinement applique des dispositions
qui demande de leur part d'exercer leur
discernement comme le dit le ministre de
l'intérieur autrement dit leur capacité
d'apprécier opportunité de prélever ou
non une amende dans des conditions qui
ouvre largement leur liberté
d'appréciation et qui se rapproche
d'une appréciation sur l'opportunité des
poursuites ou sur le la qualification
des faits qui relèvent habituellement
d'un juge ça ce sont des questions qui
nous préoccupent beaucoup nous en avons
discuté avec madame la garde des sceaux
qui a été la première membre du
gouvernement être auditionné par notre
commission et nous continuons à suivre
de très près cette problématique voilà
alors monsieur défenseur des droits vous
devez la parole pour cet ensemble de
questions qui nous sont adressées
merci monsieur le président et si vous
le permettez je voudrais commencer par
la fin c'est à dire par votre dernière
observation sur la situation de la
justice
c'est une grande préoccupation
et si je peux faire la comparaison
vous l'avez engagez vous même dans
l'état d'urgence anti terroriste les
systèmes de contrôle et notamment de
contrôle juridictionnel judiciaire ou
administratif et le compte le conseil
constitutionnel lui-même les systèmes de
contrôle ont pu s'exercer assez
largement
vous avez tous le souvenir d'un certain
nombre de décisions prises par le
conseil d'état par exemple et y compris
sur la suggestion du défenseur des
droits quand il s'agissait par exemple
de savoir comment traiter les enfants
dans les perquisitions par exemple ou de
décision du conseil constitutionnel qui
ont interprété et restreint les
possibilités de la police administrative
et les mesures de caractère
administratif
nous nous avons en fait nous avons on le
voit bien avec le confinement en quelque
sorte le blocage de la justice c'est un
des éléments sur le président
essentielles de l'état d'urgence c'est à
dire la possibilité qu il
à contrôler et contrôler en temps utile
qui a été amoindri je nie pas supprimée
car le la juridiction administrative a
été saisie à de nombreuses reprises je
l' ai moi même évoqué il ya un instant
mais c'est une remarque extrêmement
importante et et jeu et je pense que
c'est une réflexion qu'il faudra faire
pour l'avenir car les principes mêmes de
l'état de droit exige que les mesures
qui sont nécessaires proportionnée
exceptionnelle temporaire les quatre
caractéristiques des mesures de l'état
d'urgence soit aussi contrôler puissent
faire l'objet de recours et que ces
recours soit examinée que ce soit dans
le cadre de l'article 66 devant des
juridictions judiciaires
où que ce soit tout simplement lorsqu'il
s'agit de police administrative ou la
police spéciale en quelque sorte de la
loi du 23 mars
cette police sanitaire devant la
juridiction administrative le et le
conseil d'état
c'est un point extrêmement important est
de 2,2 de souci si je reviens en arrière
et je vais donc prendre dans l'ordre
marie pierre de la gontrie
je dirais sur les centres de rétention
administrative
si j'ai pris vendredi dernier de nouveau
une position samedi dernier de nos
bonnes dispositions très forte demandant
qu'il soit mis fin à l'arrivée de
retenue dans ses centres et que même ces
centres soient fermés c'est tout
simplement que depuis la décision qui a
été prise par le conseil d'état et qui
uniquement sur la base de la situation
sanitaire sans avoir examiné la question
de la légalité mais simplement sur la
base de la situation sanitaire
sonnés les cra mais depuis sont
intervenus en particulier les
inspections du contrôle général la
situation à vincennes et au mesnil
amelot qui a montré qu' il y avait des
cas et qu'il y avait des contagions que
on a décidé de fermer vincennes ce qui
montre bien qu'il ya un problème est de
concentrer sur le mesnil amelot
c'est à dire qu'on a pris une mesure
exactement à l'encontre de ce qu'on
appelle la distanciation discours encore
on a fait une mesure de concentration
sur un centre tout ça fait que je pense
qu'il existe des éléments nouveaux par
rapport à la décision prise par le
conseil d'état et qui devrait conduire
le gouvernement comme je les dis dans
une lettre que j'ai adressée il ya deux
ou trois jours au ministre de
l'intérieur à reconsidérer sa sa
position sur les la suite des
dépositions des avis du du défenseur des
droits j'ai eu l'occasion de le dire
tout à l'heure au long de mon exposé il
ya un certain nombre de points sur
lesquels les alertes en quelque sorte
que j'ai lancé ont été suivies d'effet
en particulier sur les attestations
mais d'autres cas c'est le cas des cra
on ne sanaa pas été le cas
nous nous avons évidemment vous l'avez
dit madame de la gontrie des difficultés
s'agissant de des droits des étrangers
et en particulier le blocage des
demandes d'asile nous avons là une
situation qui n'est pas normale et qui
naturellement privés de leurs droits
fondamentaux
un certain nombre de personnes sur ce
top cow vide
je le dis pour plusieurs personnes qui
vont poser cette question jean yves
leconte notamment à la fin et d'autres
de vos et madame esther benbassa aussi
et il la question qui me paraît se poser
c'est que un système volontaire ne
serait pas une dérogation à la directive
de 2000 ou 2001 sur la vie privée et
dans ces conditions quel n'exigerait pas
la mise en application de l'article 15
de cette directive qui pour qu'on puisse
faire une dérogation exige que soit
votée une loi de dérogation donc au delà
du débat que vous aurez et de du vote
que vous ferez mais qui sera un vote
indicatif
dans l'état actuel des choses dans
l'état des propositions qui nous disent
qu'ils ont été présentés notamment par
cédric au dernièrement eux
je ne crois pas qu'il y aurait la
nécessité de passer à une nouvelle loi
mais mais je pense que de manière
générale sont mises en cause par tous
ces systèmes qui consiste en réalité à
mettre de l'automaticité dans le
traitement médical préventif ou curatif
dans tous ces systèmes une des données
essentielles qui est mise en cause
c'est le droit fondamental du malade ou
du malade putatif au consentement et au
consentement au traitement qui lui est
fait à titre préventif à titre curatif
et nous l'avons dit notamment
et vous l'avez dit vous-même lorsque
vous allez examiner le projet de loi sur
la bioéthique
en ce qui concerne l'extension des
possibilités de la télémédecine et de
télédiagnostic aujourd'hui nous y sommes
les circonstances exceptionnelles
conduiront peut-être à prendre un
certain nombre de dispositions si cette
application paraît utile et si on reste
dans le cadre que la cnil aura
l'occasion de fixer mais
mais je je crois que de manière plus
générale il va falloir que l'on
s'interroge sur l'édifice de la loi de
2002 sur les droits des malades qui est
une loi entrée aujourd'hui dans nos
principes fondamentaux et qui risque
d'être mise en cause par l'utilisation
des nouvelles technologies
j'ajoute simplement de manière
informatique que nous ne sommes pas un
membre consultatif de la cnil nous nous
sommes souvent saisie pour avis par la
cnil
la cnil tient une séance vendredi pour
l'instant nous n'avons pas encore été
conviés à éventuellement y participer à
titre consultatif mais ce que je peux
dire c'est que par l'intermédiaire des
secrétariats généraux des deux maisons
nous avons des contacts très étroits
avec la cnil et je pense que sur ce
sujet bien entendu comme je l'aï dit
tout à l'heure il faut s'en remettre à
aux avis et opposition de l'autorité
compétente qui est la commission
nationale de l'informatique et des
libertés présidée aujourd'hui par
marie-laure denis
madame verbier sur les enfants vous avez
très bien dit les difficultés telles que
nous les les constate ans et là le 119
c'est vrai j'ai dit tout à l'heure qu'il
fallait absolument que l'on puisse le
saisir autrement que par téléphone donc
aussi par mail j'ai souligné comme vous
la difficulté des visites des
professionnels non seulement
naturellement la séparation des enfants
renvoyés dans leurs familles ou au
contraire
confiné dans les croyait séparés de leur
famille
mais tout ça implique que les
professionnels puissent intervenir pour
faire notamment des visites à domicile
faire des vérifications et nous nous
avons la nécessité comme vous l'avez
très bien dit de protéger
les professionnels pour qu'ils puissent
agir nous nous nous avons été alertés
sur le fait que pour les évaluations des
situations d'enfants en danger
c'est à dire les informations
préoccupantes
on nous dit d'après tous les remontées
que nous avons que seulement la moitié
des évaluations des informations
préoccupantes sont aujourd'hui assurées
par les commissions régionales parlées
crypte et donc ça veut dire qu'il ya de
très nombreux cas qui ne sont pas
aujourd'hui hélas lui est en tout cas
évaluer en temps utile je rappelle
d'ailleurs que il faut toujours on peut
toujours appeler le 17 ou saisir
directement le parquet qui s'il y a des
situations urgentes d'enfants en danger
naturellement et sur la reconnaissance
des salariés en protection de l'enfance
je dirais que ce qui avait été oubliée
aujourd'hui a été corrigé leurs enfants
peuvent être pris en en garde ou dans
les écoles comme les enfants des
soignants mais c'est vrai que nous nous
avons véritablement une une
une situation extrêmement lourde de tous
et de tous ces professionnels
bien entendu comme vous le savez mieux
que personne nous sommes dans une
situation de pouvoirs et de compétences
décentralisées
nous avons des retraités rapport elle
entendue avec l'association des
départements de france
ce que nous pouvons craindre et nous
avons quelques exemples à travers des
réclamations
c'est que les situations sont un peu
différentes il ya les difficultés
partout mais que les situations sont un
peu différentes suivant les
demande et que là encore nous trouvions
une inégalité territoriale qui
s'ajoutent aux inégalités sociales
monsieur marc ajustements très bien
insisté sur les inégalités dont sont
victimes les personnes qui vivent dans
les territoires ruraux nous avons je
parlais à l'heure du travail des
délégués territoriaux qui continuent à
être disponible nous avons été saisis
aussi bien par des personnes en milieu
urbain qu'en milieu rural et sur la
poste dès la fin du mois de mars
j'ai saisi monsieur val le président
d'accor ce de la paix de la poste
justement de ces inégalités des du fait
que des personnes allaient devoir faire
pour aller toucher notamment leur rsa ou
les autres allocations en espèces des
dizaines de kilomètres pour trouver un
bureau de poste la situation depuis une
quinzaine de jours je crois je crois
réellement s'est progressivement
amélioré je crois qu'il faut en
remercier
les postiers naturellement mais nous
sommes encore loin du compte et en
particulier pour les zones rurales
madame cost vous avez posé une question
que nous avons posée dès le début dans
la tribune que nous avons cosigné avec
jean marie burguburu et adeline hazan
dès le milieu du mois de mars dès le 20
ou 22 ou 23 mars
nous avons souligné la situation des
enfants qui étaient enfermés en
établissement pour mineurs et de manière
générale des enfants qui sont en
quartier e mineur
nous pensons que il faut absolument que
des dispositions particulières soient
prises pour accélérer les mesures de
mise en liberté des mineurs incarcérés
comme cela est malade belloubet vous l'a
dit au cours de son audition comme cela
a été fait naturellement de manière
générale pour tous les détenus adultes
il faut des mesures spécifiques parce
que c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui le travail
éducatif qui est au coeur de la mission
d au thème n'est plus fait est que nous
avons cherché notamment à développer a
développé par en mettant en place par
exemple un programme que le défenseur
des droits a développé depuis deux ou
trois ans qui s'appelle éduque à droite
et une initiation ou droit mais qui
n'est pas naturellement de
l'enseignement donc nous cherchons à
pallier à travers notre site
ces difficultés mais c'est très loin du
compte et je pense que ces mineurs
incarcérés doivent faire l'objet de
dispositions particulières de la part
des juges d'application des peines et de
la part de l'administration
pénitentiaire sur sur les maynats je
répète ce que j'ai dit nous avons
beaucoup de services qui sont fermés
nous avons beaucoup de départements qui
en quelque sorte ont décidé de renvoyer
à plus tard la mise à l'abri et
l'évaluation des maynats ils sont à la
rue
ils sont dans des hôtels c'est vrai et
nous sommes tout à fait préoccupé je
répète ce que j'ai souvent dit devant
vous les mineurs non accompagnés ne sont
pas des étrangers
ce sont des mineurs et ils doivent être
traités en tant que tels et notamment au
titre des droits de l'enfant madame
benbassa vous avez évoqué les
perspectives en quelque sorte de
surveillance sociale généralisée que
peut comporter la mise en place pour une
situation sanitaire d'urgence des deux
méthodes et d'applications tels que stop
qu'ovide j'ai évoqué tout à l'heure en
répondant à madame lherbier et où comme
je leur réponds à monsieur le comtois de
même
est ce qu'il faut est ce qu'il faut
aujourd'hui dans l'état d'urgence
sanitaire
une loi particulière je ne le crois pas
si l'application reste à la
disposition de ceux qui voudront bien
l'utiliser et non pas obligatoire mais
je pense que dans l'avenir si on veut en
particulier pour les futures difficultés
sanitaires mettre en place de nouvelles
dispositions
je pense qu'il faudra appliquer
l'article 15 de la directive sur la vie
privée de la directive communautaire sur
la vie privée est passé par une par une
loi qui je dirais ne sera pas seulement
une loi qui concerne le domaine
numérique mais qui de manière générale
traitera comme je l'aï dit tout à
l'heure la question de ce que devient le
consentement des malades droit
fondamental dans toutes ces affaires de
en quelque sorte mise en oeuvre
automatique de mesures sanitaires de
prévention ou de ou de soins madame
mercier vous allez c'est votre
spécialité
nous avons l'occasion souvent d'en
parler ensemble vous vous avez très bien
évoqué la situation des enfants
j'ai eu comme je vous le rappeler une
longue audio conférence avec le secret
d'état abri attaqué il y a quelques
jours nous avons échangé nos nos
expériences et croyez bien que s'il y a
quelque chose qui n'est pas un angle
mort de l'état d'urgence sanitaire
pour le défenseur des droits et pour la
défenseure des enfants geneviève adlard
qui nous écoutent
c'est naturellement le défenseur des
droits je lui ai dit de mon exposé et je
le redis c'est une des situations
prioritaires pour neuf parce que il ne
conte pas oublier que on parle beaucoup
aujourd'hui des des syndromes post
traumatiques
on parle beaucoup de quelles seront les
conséquences psychologiques psychosocial
de cette longue période de de
confinement et et de là je dirais
peur qui s'est emparée de notre société
et de l'enfermement dans lequel nous
nous avons été nous sommes comme
aujourd'hui
n'oublions pas que ce sera pour les
enfants pour les adolescents
probablement que les conséquences seront
les plus fortes et les plus durables et
il faut donc que cette période là
quelles que soient les difficultés et
notamment les difficultés de faire
fonctionner les établissements de l'aide
sociale à l'enfance ne soit pas une
période traumatique qui entraîne
naturellement ensuite beaucoup de
difficultés post traumatique
jean yves lecomte g g le nous avons vous
avez évoqué la situation des cra je
crois effectivement que en guyane ou à
mayotte continue à se faire un certain
nombre d'expulsions dans les territoires
proches
c'est à dire là le brésil ou surinam ou
les comores la république d'aider des
comores mais mais pour le reste je
maintiens ce que nous avons dit ce qui a
été dit au conseil d'état nous avons une
réelle impossibilité de réaliser ce
pourquoi la rétention administrative est
fait et ce pour quoi elle est faite
uniquement je le rappelle madame la
sénatrice messieurs les sénateurs
l'arrêt les personnes qui sont retenus
administrativement sont des personnes
qui font l'objet de mesures
d'éloignement du territoire et la
rétention administrative est fait pour
que cette mesure d'éloignement puissent
être prises mais ce ne sont pas des
personnes qui sont en quelque sorte des
étrangers en situation irrégulière
ils sont des personnes qui on
fait l'objet d'une mesure d'éloignement
qu'il s'agit d'appliquer mais ils sont
encadrés dans des dispositions
législatives
ce ne sont pas des hors la loi et je ne
crois pas donc qu'il faille traiter la
question d'invitation administratives
comme une question semble-t-il comme le
fait le ministère l'intérieur comme une
question de fait c'est véritablement une
question de droit sur la situation des
français à l'étranger
nous avons eu effectivement quelques
saisies mais nous allons vous le savez
gates avait fait partie de notre réseau
territorial bien qu'est le siège au
oui je pense que je ne perde tout petit
peu payet ilan et je ne vous entends jeu
j'étais en train de terminer monsieur le
président il est il est clair que nous
nous avons jeu en ce qui concerne
puisque jean yves le conte l'a également
évoqué je les dis à esther benbassa et à
madame lherbier jeu madame de la gontrie
je vous le dis je vous le dis à tous il
me paraît clair que cette situation ce
qui je l'espère restera ponctuelles
appel de votre part à des réflexions et
à des prises de position sur ce sujet
pour donner une idée vous savez que moi
aussi indépendamment d'une situation
aussi dramatique que celle que nous
connaissons aujourd'hui je suis en train
par exemple de travailler sur les pieds
discriminatoire qui peuvent exister dans
les algorithmes les algorithmes de
l'intelligence artificielle les talgo
rythme de tous les systèmes automatiques
et cette réflexion
elle est tout à fait en lien avec ce qui
est en train de se passer parce que
naturellement ceux ci existent dans le
domaine de la santé
mais ce n'est pas seulement dans le
je voudrais juste répondre à jean yves
le conte pour dire que je confirme que à
notre connaissance depuis la fin du mois
de mars
il n'y a pas eu d'expulsion à partir des
centres de rétention administrative de
vincennes et du mesnil amelot et que
donc encore une fois la décision prise
par le conseil d'état et donc on peut
penser ce qu'on veut
mais elle prise sur la base d'une
situation sanitaire et du fait que les
expulsions se plonge se poursuivaient
aujourd'hui la situation est nouvelle et
c'est bien pour ça que nous avons
relancé le sujet mais monsieur
présidente je conclurai simplement d'un
mot pour dire que votre comité de suivi
et est aujourd'hui un comité de suivi
il doit devenir demain un comité de
projet parce que je crois que la
situation qui s'impose à nous
aujourd'hui amène naturellement à
réfléchir sur ce qu'on appelle le monde
d'après je ne vais pas la faire le café
du commerce
bien entendu mais sur le plan des droits
et des libertés
c'est un monde qui doit monsieur le
président je pense que les sénateurs et
dessinatrice en sont d'accord avec moi
être continuer à être celui de l'état de
droit et de la démocratie et en
particulier de la liberté d'expression
de la liberté d'aller et de venir de la
vie privée nous avons mis trois siècles
aller conquérir et il ne faut pas que
nous soyons a vaincu mais hier par les
barbares ni aujourd'hui par le drame de
la delà de la maladie
je crois que il appartient au parlement
d'être à l'avant-garde non seulement de
la réflexion mais des projets qu'encore
une fois droits et libertés reste au
centre
merci monsieur le défenseur des droits
de cette recommandation impérieuse qui
rejoint d'ailleurs tout à fait dans
notre propre direction de v je vais cela
aurait pu être le mot de la fin mai
notre collègue sophie joissains me
demande de la parole je vais lui donne
volontiers car il nous reste six minutes
merci alors chère sophie joissains vous
avez la parole
bonjour
un voisin alors lui donne la lègue
encore faut-il qu'elle l'apprenne madame
joissains entendez oui madame oui nous
préciser et suis désolé de ne pas avoir
pris la parole avant mais j'ai des
problèmes de manipulation et de réseaux
donc simplement j'aurais souhaité vous
vous demandez ce que vous pensiez delà
du prolongement de plein droit de deux à
six mois de la détention provisoire
c'est toujours une question il a été
dommage pas d'apposer allez y messieurs
deux défenseurs des premières marches on
pense du mal je d'abord pour une raison
simplement de fait elle me paraît
contradictoire avec la politique
justifiée et que nous avons souhaité
d'allègement de la stir population
carcérale et qui aujourd'hui se pratique
à la fois par le fait que l' on
emprisonne
- les décisions des juges au départ
conduisent à moins emprisonnée par
exemple beaucoup rire au travail et de
l'autre côté qu' on prend des mesures de
libération plus nombreuses et et
anticiper et ça conduit donc à
l'allègement dont on va parler c'est à
dire probablement plus de dix mille
détenus en en moins mais il est certain
que le fait de doubler automatiquement
de prolonger automatiquement les
détentions provisoires et de pouvoir
bien entendu la toile l'ordonnancé
prévoit demander une mise en liberté
mais on sait aujourd'hui à quel point
comme votre président a souligné le
système de la justice est embouteillée
je n'ai pas répondu d'ailleurs tout à
l'heure à une observation qui a été fait
et qui est très très juste c'est vrai je
crois que c'est marie pierre de la
gontrie qu'il a dit les conseils de
prud'hommes ne fonctionne plus et nous
allons nous retrouver et nous allons
nous retrouver à au moment du des
confirmands plus tard nous allons nous
retrouver avec une sorte de grosse
or qui va se détendre pour la
juridiction des relations du travail qui
va être extrêmement préoccupante je
ferme 7
cette parenthèse donc nous nous avons
effectivement une disposition dont je
crois pour ma part que elle n'est pas
elle n'est pas justifiée n'est pas n'est
pas cohérente
alors après la question et sur le plan
juridique il a été dit que cela ne
posait pas de problème moi je l'aider
j'ai eu l'occasion le dire une fois ce
serait très intéressant si cette
question pourrait être posée au conseil
constitutionnel le constitutionnel dans
sa décision sur la loi organique qui
accompagnait la loi sur l'état d'urgence
a dit que les délais pour l'examen des
qpc était donc prolonger mais que ça ne
voulait pas dire que le conseil ne se
prononcerait pas sur des qpc qui lui
seraient soumises maintenant et en
particulier sur l'application de l'état
d'urgence c'est une question qui
mériterait d'être examiné par le conseil
constitutionnel sous forme d'une qpc à
la suite par exemple de la décision d'un
juge de la liberté et de la détention ou
d'une chambre de l'instruction je pense
que la théorie que concessionnels à
adopter et qui s'appelle les
circonstances de l'espèce les
circonstances spéciales de l'espèce et
qui a fondé sa décision récente sur la
loi organique pourrait être utilisée par
exemple d'un jeu notre sens est
considéré que dans les
confiant spéciale de l'espèce la
prolongation de la détention provisoire
est une mesure qui est au contraire aux
objectifs d'intérêt général que se donne
l'état d'urgence sanitaire
très bien merci beaucoup monsieur le
défenseur des droits il est pile 10h45
je vous remercie d'avoir contribué par
la concision de vos réponses respecter
l'horaire qui nous était imparti de vous
remercie de la qualité de ses réponses
et de l'éclairage que vous avez apporté
à la commission des lois
la séance est donc levée de vous
remercie tous d'y avoir participé
merci voilà pour cette audition de
jacques toubon le défenseur des droits
qui s'est exprimé devant le comité de
suivi de l'état d'urgence sanitaire
présidé par philippe bas et vous l'aurez
constaté en visio conférence l'occasion
pour le défenseur de droit de livrer
l'état de ses réflexions sur nos droits
et nos libertés
lors de cet état d'urgence sanitaire il
s'est exprimé sur des sujets très divers
allant de la poste aux attestations de
déplacement en passant par la question
des sans abri ou encore les conditions
de détention et de rétention notez
d'ailleurs que jacques toubon a
notamment estimé qu'il n'avait pas eu
beaucoup de saisine pas beaucoup de
réclamations envers le défenseur des
droits sur la question du comportement
des forces de l'ordre sur cet état
d'urgence sanitaire tout de suite donc
on va prendre la direction maintenant de
les mystique où se poursuit l'examen du
projet de loi de finances rectificative
ce deuxième budget rectificatif qui
actent notamment et bien ce plan
d'urgence de 110 milliards d'euros
il a été adopté vendredi dernier à
l'assemblée nationale il est débattu
depuis hier dans l'hémicycle du sénat
au menu des discussions ce matin bien
parmi les amendements du sénat noté
l'exonération des heures supplémentaires
depuis le 16 mars 2020 c'est une volonté
et sénateurs et puis aussi l'abaissement
de la tva à 5,5 pour cent pour les
tenues de protection au lieu de 20%
alors que déjà a été adoptée
l'abaissement de ce taux de tva pour les
masques de protection mais aussi pour
les gels hydroalcooliques tout de suite
donc on prend la direction de
l'hémicycle l'ordre du jour appelle la
suite de la discussion du projet de loi
de finances rectificative adoptée par
l'assemblée nationale pour 2020 dans la
discussion des articles nous sommes
parvenus amendement 3,235 tendant à
insérer un article additionnel après
l'article 1er qui le défend le président
marseille
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
cet amendement est un une amorce du
débat que nous aurons plus tard sur
l'annulation des charges fiscales et
sociales qui a mobilisé mon groupe déjà
depuis plus de dix jours et beaucoup sur
ces bancs partage cette intention se
trouve que dans notre ordre du jour
l'amendement de mon groupe concernant
l'annulation des décharges a été
reportée après l'article 1 qu'inquiets
c'est avec l'amendement dieu 206 dur dur
à porter donc on se trouve un peu décalé
j'allais dire du fait de cette
présentation
mais ça permet de de commencer à avoir
ce débat que nous nous aurons un peu
plus tard concernant l'annulation des
charges à l'évidence évidence cette
crise met en grande difficulté voire en
péril de nombreuses pme de nombreuses
de nombreux commerces de nombreuses
activités et le report à nos yeux n'est
pas pertinent on ne peut pas demander à
des gens qui ne m'ont pas avoir de
recettes pendant des semaines pendant
des mois qu'ils ne savent pas quand ils
vont pouvoir recommencer à travailler et
avec quels débouchés de payer des taxes
et des charges
un moment qui ne connaissent pas au
demeurant est donc à l'évidence si on
veut les aider il faut annuler ces
charges sur une période donnée
alors le ministre de l'économie a fait
un pas en avant en disant que
publiquement que les métiers de la
restauration et de l'hôtellerie était
prioritaire et que et personne n'en
disconvient et qu'on pourrait regarder
au cas par cas
l'annulation des charges je crois qu'il
faut aller quelques vers quelque chose
de beaucoup plus systématique de
beaucoup plus fort et veiller à aller
vers une annulation des charges sur une
période donnée et pour un certain nombre
d'activités
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous avons
proposé comme d'autres y aura de
nombreux amendements sur ce sujet tout à
l'heure l'annulation des charges
fiscales et sociales pour autant se
trouve cet amendement devait se
retrouver avec les autres le hasard de
la séance fait qu'ils se retrouvent
plutôt ici et donc c'était un amendement
de repli sur un report sur plusieurs
années de ces taxes au cas où elle
n'aurait pas été annulée mais j'espère
bien que tout à l'heure dans le débat
nous aboutirons avec le gouvernement à
une annulation des charges fiscales et
sociales
merci monsieur rapporteur avec ce gel
président monsieur ministre je regardais
marseille a introduit le débat nous
leurrons tout à l'heure il annoncé lui
même que cet amendement et venait
prématurément par rapport à d'autres
genres que la citation est très clair
vous avez des entreprises qui ne
pourront pas payer et notamment
notamment celles dont l'activité
continuera à être interdit dans quelque
sorte par décision administrative
au delà de la date du 11 mai est d'ores
et déjà le gouvernement le prendrais
public ont annoncé des secteurs pour
lesquels on sait qu'il n'y aura pas de
réouverture le 11 mai la zone avait cité
la restauration par exemple ça donne de
métier à le tourisme dans l'événementiel
tous ces métiers sont très fortement
impactés c'est évident et n'ont aucun
chiffre d'affaires à un moment qui est
pour eux sans doute le meilleur moment
de l'année dans l'événementiel dans les
métiers de traiteur et autres c'est
évident que les mois de mai juin les
mois d'été sont les meilleurs mois en
général
donc je pense qu'il faut regarder les
choses en face et c'est la raison pour
laquelle je vous proposerai tout à
l'heure vous l'avait annoncé un
amendement qui vise tout simplement à ne
pas reporter indéfiniment des charges
qui ne pourront pas en définitive être
payés mais permet simplement à les
annuler et je proposerai un mécanisme de
crédit d'impôt pour les entreprises dont
l'activité restera possible au delà du
lait du 11 mai donc je pense que ça va
un peu au-delà satisfait sur le fond ce
que vous souhaitez puisque vous proposé
un étalement et donc cher que la garde à
marseille je vous invite à vous rallié à
l'amendement la commission des finances
tout à l'heure monsieur le ministre
merci monsieur le président mais
monsieur le rapporteur général monsieur
le président la commission des finances
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs sur
le président marseille c'est une demande
de retrait du goût du gouvernement pour
deux raisons essentiellement
indépendamment du fait que le débat
viendra dans un instant sur les
annulations vous l'avez dit la première
raison c'est que nous avons eu
l'occasion dans plusieurs roquettes ont
plusieurs enceintes de dire quelles
étaient les mesures mises en place par
le gouvernement
cela a été rappelé par le rapporteur est
à vous même le ministre de l'économie
des finances comme le ministre de
l'action des comptes publics ont annoncé
qu'un certain nombre de secteurs ferait
l'objet d'annulation dans des conditions
de respect notamment du droit
communautaire et par ailleurs vous
proposer dans cet amendement c'est la
troisième raison qui explique ma demande
de retrait un plan d'étalement des
charges vous présentez vous même comme
une solution de repli sur 15 ans or
aujourd'hui à droit constant
les plans proposés ne peuvent excéder
deux ans nous travaillons à des plans
plus long ils seront certainement
nécessaires et nous travaillons aussi à
des modalités d'accès ainsi plus en plus
longues que deux ans mais pas
nécessairement de 15 qui sont des
modalités plus automatiques et donc au
bénéfice de ses explications et dans
l'attendu débats que nous aurons tout à
l'heure c'est une demande de retrait ou
à défaut ces freins avid et favre
merci monsieur le ministre il est retiré
l'amendement est retiré nous passons aux
91 c'est monsieur tissot oui merci
monsieur le président de fumistes chers
collègues
cet amendement vise à interdire le
versement de dividendes en 2020 aux
sociétés ayant bénéficié de la
solidarité nationale dans le cadre de
l'état d'urgence sanitaire
au regard de la gravité de la situation
économique et des mobilisations massives
de la puissance publique le ministre de
l'économie et des finances a demandé aux
entreprises qui bénéficient des aides
publiques garanties chômage partiel
fonds d'indemnisation de renoncer au
versement de dividendes en 2020 à ce
stade cette demande relève de la seule
intention
ainsi cet amendement vise à inscrire
dans la loi l'engagement demandé par le
ministre de l'économie et des finances
aux entreprises concernées il est
interdit donc le versement dividende en
2020 aux sociétés quelle que soit leur
forme juridique ayant bénéficié d'au
moins une des aides directes ou
indirectes de l'état mise en oeuvre pour
amortir les effets économiques de la
crise ne sont concernés que les cessions
que les sociétés dont le total de bilan
est supérieur à 20 millions d'euros ou
dont le chiffre d'affaires est supérieur
à 40 millions d'euros
il s'agit ainsi d' exclure les petites
entreprises entreprises de l'économie
sociale et solidaire où les grecs par
exemple afin de ne pas décourager
l'actionnaire populaire cette
interdiction s'étend à toute forme de
dividendes y compris les avancer les
intérêts sur premier dividende qu'il
soit en numéraire ou en actions
l'amendement prévoit également que toute
délibération des actionnaires qui
contreviendrait à ses disques
à ces dispositions seraient nulles il
prévoit également une sanction en cas de
non respect de cette interdiction avec
une amende correspondant au montant ou à
la valeur des dividendes ainsi versé
majoré de 5 % du chiffre d'affaires
mondial consolidé je vous remercie
chers collègues sur le rapporteur
j'avais d'autres collègues a retiré son
amendement parce que il nous semble dans
l'état actuel satisfait puisque le
gouvernement
mais le ministre est au bain de sang est
venu le confirmer nous indiquer que le
contrat de prêt le contrat de prêt
garantis par l'état pour les grandes
entreprises prévoyait l'interdiction de
ne pas distribuer dividendes depuis 20
ou une entreprise deux mois sont engagés
et s'il ne respecte pas cette clause
il ya une clause résolutoire dans le
texte même du contrat qui dit que
l'entreprise doit procéder à un
remboursement assorti d'un intérêt de
retard de 0 2 5% +0 2 point ensuite
donc concrètement le contrat de prêt
lui-même nous a dit le gouvernement mais
le ministre ne confirmer le contrat de
prêt lui même prévoit cet engagement de
ne pas verser dividendes et à défaut
l'obligation de rembourser les 10 villes
de le rembourser avec intérêts de retard
donc ne paraître une clause encore plus
favorables que ce que prévoit votre
amendement s'ils gagnent on le confirme
je vous invite à le retirer
merci monsieur le ministre et le
président je confirme ce que dit
monsieur le rapporteur concernant les
contrats qui encadrent l'accès aux prêts
garantis par l'état
j'ajoute que nous procédons de la même
manière pour les questions de reports
d'échéances fiscales ou sociales puisque
nous demandons aux entreprises aux plus
grandes entreprises et cela rejoint
votre objectif de s'engager à ne pas
verser de dividende
si elles souhaitent bénéficier de
l'accompagnement de l'état et donc votre
amendement satisfait parce que nous
pratiquons merci il est retiré monsieur
tissot oui au vu des explications
monsieur le ministre oui merci et
retirer le 99 madame taille et pau lyon
mais monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues il s'agit
d'interdire aux entreprises qui auraient
bénéficié du versement anticipé du
crédit impôt recherche pour 2020 de
verser des dividendes de la même année
c'est un peu le même état d'esprit c'est
à dire de se dire que quand on fait des
avances sans trésorerie un certain
nombre d'entreprises qui pour autant
n'ont pas forcément besoin ça quand même
des entreprises qui continuent à leur
activité
on propose là sans conditionnalité sauf
erreur de ma part des remboursements
anticipés
de crédit d'impôt ça me semble pas
approprié il faut conditionner ses aides
c'est évident merci monsieur rapporteur
c'est un avis défavorable
il n'y a pas de rapport entre le crédit
impôt recherche qui lisent à financer la
recherche et une entreprise faveur
besoin de financer 500 de recherches
pour connaître par ailleurs des
difficultés temporaires de trésorerie
dues à une baisse d'activité due à une
fermeture administrative qui plonge et
des supers être temporaire qui doit être
temporaire et avoir besoin un instant
d'après de sa banque soit garantie par
l'état
donc concrètement interdire aux
entreprises de bénéficier du prêt
garanti par l'état dès lors qu'elle
essayait s'est mélangé de problèmes lien
l'un lié à la zone financer la recherche
et l'autre des mesures d'extrême urgence
destiné je le pense à financer des
mesures le bhoutan portr possible donc
avis défavorable merci monsieur le
ministre c'est le même avis monsieur le
président pour les mêmes raisons nous
tenons à ce que le crédit impôt
recherche soient accessibles aux
entreprises qui innovent qui prête qui
sont dans la recherche et que ça ne soit
pas conditionnée que ça ne sera pas une
condition pour accéder ou non aux
accompagnements nous et on place donc
favorable il est maintenu et madame
taipei lyon il est maintenu je le mets
aux voix avec deux avis défavorables qui
et pour qui et contre qui s'abstient il
n'est pas adopté le 194e l'an dernier
merci monsieur le président monsieur
ministre chers collègues
cet amendement a pour but d'encourager
les entreprises avec des mesures
fiscales incitatives pour l'année 2020 a
participé aux recettes du fonds de
solidarité mis en place par l'état dans
cet esprit
cet amendement s'inspire des mesures
votées dans le cadre de la souscription
nationale votée en 2019 pour les travaux
de restauration de la cathédrale notre
dame de paris et prévoit de porter à 75%
le taux de déduction d'impôt pour les
entreprises au lieu de 60% actuellement
l'augmentation de ces déductions
fiscales n'a pour seul objectif que de
permettre de nouvelles sources de
financement dans la durée pour
accompagner la reprise économique post
crise et ainsi consolider notre réseau
de petites entreprises où travaillent un
très grand nombre de
salariés non délocalisables et qui
participent à la richesse de nos
territoires
les fonds ainsi collectés seront
réinvestis localement et viendront
s'ajouter à la solidarité nationale
engagée par l'état je vous remercie
merci cher collègue monsieur le
rapporteur l'idée est bonne demander aux
entreprises de participer au fonds de
solidarité en les incitant fiscalement
la seule difficulté c'est que
l'amendement de ne comporte pas de
limites puisque vous avez vous fait
sauter la limite de 5 pour mille du
chiffre d'affaires d'une part et et vous
avez hâte aux déductions qui est
évidemment très favorable ça veut dire
tout simplement que les entreprises
auraient évidemment intérêt ne plus
payer 10 aces mais a tous versé à titre
du de cette réduction d'impôt mécénat
hier nous avons eu un exemple un débat
sur la contribution des assurances ce
fonds de solidarité
je ne suis pas sûr que ce soit très
opportun les assurances par exemple les
assureurs se précipiteraient sur ces
dispositions parce que par définition ça
leur permettrait de ne plus payer
d'impôts sur les sociétés
le coût de la réponse viendrait 25% et
ça veut dire concrètement c'est
évidemment celle ce serait extrêmement
favorable donc ça fera une sorte de
super réduction par exemple pour les
campagnes et des sciences donc je pense
que ça provoquerait des baisses de prix
n'a pas de limite encore une fois les
vies de 5 pour mille des baisses de
produits de liesse qui déjà on l'a vu
hier je les dis dans le propos
introductif le garnement l'a confirmé le
produit liesse et des gens très très
forte baisse sur vous permet aux
entreprises de déduire 75 % lors y est
sous forme de dons je pense qu'elles
vont se précipiter sur le dispositif une
recette fiscale
on se ferait beaucoup c'est une demande
de retraite c'est demande de retrait oui
pardon lâche ministre même avis monsieur
le président une demande de retrait pour
les raisons évoquées et durer une forme
d' effets d'aubaine qui je crois n'est
pas votre objectif
par ailleurs l'entreprise ont fait le
choix de participer au fonds de solide
et de solidarité nationale dans les
conditions actuelles nous nous en
remercions puisque leur contribution est
utile pour financer les dispositifs
qui sont ainsi mises en place donc
demande de retrait ou à défaut
défavorable merci il est maintenu ou
retirés au tir et donc il est retiré le
156 madame delattre oui merci monsieur
le président monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues le code du travail
permet à certains établissements dont le
fonctionnement ou l'ouverture est rendue
nécessaire par les contraintes de la
production de l'activité ou des besoins
du public de déroger à la règle du repos
dominical en attribuant le repos
hebdomadaire par roulement
aujourd'hui en état d'urgence sanitaire
le rythme hebdomadaire de nos semaines
de travail a été bouleversée pour de
nombreuses chaînes de production
d'acheminement de distribution et de
vente
les jours se ressemblent et se suivent
elle tourne au service de nos
concitoyens 24 heures sur 24 aux fins de
leur garantir les biens les plus
essentiels et les services les plus
élémentaires
ces travailleurs hier invisible se
révèle aujourd'hui il est de notre
devoir de leur dire merci
avant de penser demain une
revalorisation sociale et financière de
ces métiers lorsque nous sont sortis de
la crise dans les commerces de détail
alimentaires en grande surface notamment
les salariés peuvent bénéficier une
majoration de salaire pour le travail du
dimanche
cet amendement vise à encourager cette
pratique en défiscalisant les éventuels
majoration de rémunération dominical
aussi pour saluer le travailleur sans
relâche fournies par ce français sur
cette ligne de front
je vous encourage chers collègues à
adopter cet amendement je vous remercie
merci monsieur le rapporteur monsieur le
président monsieur nice mais je
reconnais je partage 100% ce qu'a dit
notre collègue vous avez des salariés
qui sont amenés à travailler plus
notamment le dimanche parce que d'autres
salariés sont en retrait d'autres
salariés sont en garde d'enfants
d'autres salariés sont malades et donc
ça mais sur les commerces par exemple
qui sont ouverts le dimanche une
boulangerie par exemple ça met une
certaine pression et ça oblige certains
salariés travailler plus et il est
important que ce travail supplémentaire
soit encouragée et compris par des
dispositifs tels que celui que vous
proposez simplement je vous invite à
retirer votre amendement parce que la
commission des finances un amendement
qui est plus large qui vise à exonérer
les heures supplémentaires réalisées
pendant la période de crise sanitaire
deux charges fiscales salariale et de
charges sociales patronales ainsi que da
posture le revenu au loft du forfait de
5000 euros ça nous paraît donc ça couvre
ipso facto ce que vous proposez donc y
compris le travail du dimanche croit que
c'est un signal important que de ne pas
taxer le travail supplémentaire de
salariés qui l'ont pas forcément demandé
mais qui sont ceux et celles qui
assurent au quotidien les services
essentiels pour la nation donc demande
de retrait au profit de l'amendement la
commission qui va dans le même sens en
étant plus large si monsieur ministre
merci monsieur le président c'est une
demande de retrait pour des raisons un
peu différente nous retrouvons avec sa
maman demande de ligne de partage entre
ce qui relève à nos yeux des mesures
d'urgence qui pourrait relever d'un
débat sur les mesures de relance et
d'accompagnement de la relance dont nous
considérons peut être prématuré de voter
de telles dispositions sur le travail et
les générations à ce stade de nos débats
donc c'est une demande de retrait ou à
défaut des favoris merci madame de
l'autre je le retire au motif de ce que
nous a dit le rapporteur effectivement
pour l'amendement de la commission et je
remercie le rapporteur d'avoir pris en
compte ma demande merci merci chers
collègues donc nous passons à l'article
1er bis l'amendement 340 du gouvernement
monsieur ministre merci monsieur le
président l'assemblée nationale a adopté
un amendement pour permettre la
neutralité fiscale des abandons de
créances de loyer accordés à des
entreprises quelle que soit la catégorie
d'imposition du bailleur la maman nous
proposons permet de clarifier de
corriger la rédaction de la maman
adoptée par l'assemblée en précisant son
ciblage sur les loyers afférents à des
immeubles loués par des entreprises
quelle que soit leur forme
pardon merci madame la présidente
oui ce qui est cocasse c'est
qu'habituellement on me fait plutôt le
reproche de ne pas parler assez fort
mais cette fois ci ça résonne peut-être
un peu trop c'est c'est une forme
c'est une forme d' acclimatation donc je
disais que cet amendement vise à
clarifier corrigé l'amendement de adopté
par l'assemblée nationale sur la
neutralité fiscale des des abandons
d'impôts et l'amendement propose
d'exclure du bénéfice de la mesure
les abandons de créances consentis entre
des entreprises liées
et de limiter l'application de la mesure
dans le ton dans la borne ans au 31
décembre 2020 merci monsieur le ministre
monsieur rapporteur comme c'est pour que
soient bien claires et je rajoute de
restreindre ces dispositions aux beaux
que vos sorties à des entreprises dont
concrètement vous avez des entreprises
qui ne peuvent pas payer leur loyer pour
des difficultés du fait des difficultés
actuelles du fait de la fermeture est ce
mécanisme est donc bienvenue dans le
commandement initial il était sans doute
un peu large et prévoyait tous les cas
de figure y compris même je pense les
crédits-baux mobilier lacets restreint à
l'immobilier les alliés un autre prix
dans l'immobilier notamment commerciales
donc je pense que c'est une précision
qui est bienvenu mais j'attire
l'attention du gouvernement sur le fait
que son amendement fait tomber un
rédactionnel donc une cmp que nous
espérons conclusive ça dépendra de la
bonne volonté du gouvernement
donc voilà deux avis de sagesse sur cet
amendement merci donc je me revois cet
amendement du gouvernement le 340 avec
un avis de sagesse de la commission qui
et pour qui et contre qui s'abstient il
est adopté le 202 sera porteur dont ils
n'auront précision amendement de
précision rédactionnelle monsieur
ministre favorable donc je mets au voile
202 avec un avis favorable de du
gouvernement qui et pour qui et contre
qui s'abstient il est adopté je mets ce
vous je vais au voile à l'article 1er
bis qui et pour qui et contre qui
s'abstient il est adopté après cet
article deux amendements discussion
commune de 4 34 monsieur c'est loin oui
merci monsieur le président cet
amendement propose une exonération
fiscale et sociale totale de l'ensemble
des heures supplémentaires travaillées
pendant l'état d'urgence sanitaire afin
de soutenir les salariés
particulièrement mobilisés
les heures supplémentaires sont exonérés
d'impôts sont revenus au delà du seuil
de 5000 euros ainsi que de quelques
cotisations patronales
cet amendement constitue un complément
utile à l' ordonnance du 1er avril 2020
qui juge en appel
est de verser la prime exceptionnelle de
1000 euros sans exiger d'accord
d'intéressement et en tenant compte des
conditions de travail due à la crise
sanitaire
enfin cet amendement permettra à
soutenir l'offre et le pouvoir d'achat
des salariés dans la crise mais
également lorsque la phase de relance de
l'économie sera venu ce serait dommage
que les salariés et paie beaucoup
d'impôts suite au travail qu'ils ont pu
fournir
merci merci monsieur le rapporteur
l'amendement de la commission le 203 va
dans le sens donc je me suis exprimé
l'instant vous avez des salariés qui par
choix ou par contrainte un tous les cas
sont indispensables à la vie la nation
qui travaillent est compris dans des
conditions parfois difficiles
le dimanche le samedi la nuit ça peut
être une entreprise qui produit du gel
hydroalcoolique ça peut-être commerce
qui doit rester ouvert ça va être un
transporteur routier un salarié des
transports routiers etc etc tous ces
salariés qui est malgré des conditions
de travail très difficiles continue à
travailler et travailler souvent aulas
35 heures ils le font parce que il
faudra placer également des salariés qui
sont eux mêmes absents donc je pense
qu'il faut encourager ce travail et nous
proposons donc comme le fait notre
collègue segura l'instant l'exonération
des cotisations salariales patronales et
patronales ainsi que l'exonération
d'impôt sur le revenu sur ces heures
supplémentaires
bien sûr pendant la période de la crise
sanitaire donc uniquement dû à ce
surcroît d'activité
en ce moment les activer et sachant que
les entreprises qui sont en heures
supplémentaires en ce moment ce sont
évidemment des entreprises qui sont
indispensables à la vie de la nation et
qui produisent notamment des biens
indispensables pour assurer une certaine
continuité de notre vie économique est
donc évidemment je me jetterai pas un
instant de collègues à se rallier à
l'amendement que je me présente et qui
va exactement dans le même sens
merci monsieur le ministre merci
monsieur le président nous avons des
difficultés avec les amendements
défendus à la fois par le sénateur
segouin et le rapporteur général
la première difficulté que aujourd'hui
le plafond qui fixé à 5000 euros permet
de couvrir si vous me permettez cette
expression 95% des salariés réalisant
des heures supplémentaires et les 5% qui
ne sont pas couverts ne sont pas
nécessairement en tout cas au vu des
revenus moyens des salariés concernés
parmi les plus fragiles la deuxième
difficulté que nous avons tient à la
proposition qui est faite d'exonérer les
heures supplémentaires de cotisation
patronale alors que nous avons un
dispositif qui les exonère de
cotisations salariales et d'impôts
jusqu'à 5000 euros et cela ne nous
paraît pas au portant ça ne nous
paraissait pas opportun y compris dans
la période de crise dans la mesure où
nous nous considérons que les
entreprises qui réalisent des heures
supplémentaires dans cette période de
crise ne sont pas les entreprises qui
rencontrent le plus de difficultés en
termes d'activité de chiffre d'affaires
puisque elles sont dans cette capacité à
faire travailler leurs salariés plus
entre elles ce besoin de faire
travailler leurs salariés plus longtemps
par ailleurs si nous devons réfléchir
sur des dispositifs qui encouragent
l'activité qui encourage la reprise cela
nous paraît plus relever des
dispositions autour de la relance et de
soutien qui interviendront dans un temps
ultérieure plutôt que dans la période de
crise c'est la raison pour laquelle à
l'assemblée nationale comme ici le
gouvernement un avis défavorable sur cet
amendement sollicite le retrait auprès
de leurs auteurs pour les deux raisons
que j'ai évoquées
merci monsieur le ministre monsieur
retailleau pour l'explication de vote
oui monsieur le président monsieur
ministre deux amendements de la même
facture et nous allons évidemment nous
replier sur l'amendement du rapporteur
général
l'amendement du groupe qu' à l'instant
vincent segouin a soutenu et de la même
mouture si j'ose dire monsieur le
ministre nous avons déjà dans le cadre
du plfr 1 soutenu cette mesure nous le
faisons tout simplement parce que tout
travail mérite salaire
nous le faisons parce que la prime dans
le privé est insuffisante
en quoi était insuffisante elle dépend
du libre choix d'entreprise elle dépend
de savoir si l'entreprise où ils ont
fait des bénéfices et la prime elle est
exceptionnelle tandis que la
défiscalisation et socialisation des
heures supplémentaires c'est mois après
mois vous allez le faire pour une
catégorie du public dans des
circonstances particulières pour les
soignants uniquement pour ce secteur là
ce que je veux vous dire c'est que au
moment où nous avions fait cette
proposition
vous étiez là dans l'hémicycle vous nous
aviez
répondu et vous nous avez dit nous
partageons totalement l'objectif qui
sous-tend votre amendement auxquels nous
proposons de travailler dans les
prochains jours c'est à dire que deux
vecteurs en vecteur c'est un peu comme
l'horizon
on croit s'en rapprocher et à chaque
fois vous dites ça n'est pas le moment
eh bien monsieur le ministre c'est le
moment tout de suite il ya des
françaises et des français qui sont en
première ligne sont les soignants ce
sont les caissières de supermarché ce
sont des quantités de profession qui
permettent à la france de tourner et
bien la défiscalisation des heures
supplémentaires
c'est le moyen concret de leur signifier
notre reconnaissance
nous voterons cet amendement plutôt deux
fois qu'une et j'espère que le
rapporteur général ne le retirera pas
merci monsieur besson
monsieur les sens pour explications de
vote le président monsieur le ministre
je m'inscris évidemment dans la même
veine des propos de notre rapporteur
général de vincent segouin monsieur le
ministre je crois qu'il faut faire
attention vous là le présent république
le premier ministre aujourd'hui souhaite
qu'ils aient une france rassemblée
on a là bruno retailleau vient de dire
on a ceux qui sont sur la ligne de front
c'est beaucoup
les personnels de santé médico en milieu
hospitalier mais pas seulement et puis
ses mille et un métiers de proximité que
ce soit dans les soins médicaux sociaux
puis que ce soit comme l'a dit albéric
de montgolfier sur un certain nombre
d'autres métiers savez ce que de plus en
plus ça a été dit ici que ce qu'on
appelle les invisibles et je crois que
le devoir de la nation c'est d'être
beaucoup plus reconnaissant avec ceux
qui sont en première ligne où ceux qui
sont à l'arrière et qui permettent de
fonctionner en fait notre responsabilité
mais votre responsabilité qu entend lui
exécutif c'est d'entendre cet appel
et cet appel c'est de mettre une mesure
de justice parce que vous avez évoqué
les heures supplémentaires mais vous
avez un sens tant de nos concitoyens qui
étaient dans des heurts en travail
fractionné qui ont des heures ce qu'on
appelle complémentaires
y compris les personnels de santé et
j'ai même posé la question hier il
semblerait que le ministre de la santé
ne souhaite pas accompagner un
abondement pour les
anesthésistes-réanimateurs honnêtement
monsieur le ministre
vérifier l'information si c'est le cas
c'est une forme de mépris
ce serait une forme de mépris par
rapport à ces personnels qui sont en
première ligne et donc justice équité
c'est aujourd'hui la responsabilité qui
est la vôtre
en tous les cas nous voterons évidemment
l'amendement proposé par le rapporteur
général
merci cher collègue madame dumas pour
explication de vote merci ce président
monsieur le ministre
oui moi je m'inscris évidemment aussi
dans le soutien complet cet amendement
sur la défiscalisation des heures
supplémentaires et je voudrais surtout
attirer votre attention en fait comme ça
a été dit aussi ça concerne énormément
de personnes des métiers très différents
ça concerne aussi tout le territoire
tout le monde est concerné et je
voudrais vous dire attention à ce qu au
moment de la reprise
il n'y ait pas de la confusion dans
l'esprit de tous ses acteurs ses acteurs
économiques
il faut absolument qu'on ait un cadre
réglementaire clair et souple au moment
de la reprise donc voilà pour cette
raison if je soutiens cet amendement
merci monsieur ben asher pour
explications de vote le président mais
ce ministre avait chers collègues lors
du but première loi de finances
rectificative
le sénat avait consenti à retirer c'est
amendement parce que nous voulions être
dans l'unité nationale hier nous avons
rappelé à gérald darmanin et à bruno le
maire que il était temps aussi que la
majorité présidentielle que le
gouvernement fasse preuve d'unité
nationale j'en veux pour preuve que
notre amendement a été déjà suggéré par
le président de la république
trois jours après que la lfr numéro un a
eu été votée il a commencé à dire qu'il
fallait peut-être exonérés
les heures supplémentaires eh bien nous
nous traduisons nous allons plus loin
nous allons dans les actes de la pensée
du président de la république
dans le souci de l'unité nationale et
lorsque l'on à un dit tout à l'heure
lorsque l'on a dit tout à l'heure que
hier cette nuit je veux dire que on va
essayer tout à l'heure que nous allions
des charges pour le secteur de l'hôtel
du café restaurant le tourisme et cetera
eh bien c'est exactement la même idée à
un moment il faut passer des reports ou
des paroles aux actes
on a besoin de clarté les français qui
travaillent aujourd'hui qui font des
heures supplémentaires et ce ne sont pas
les cadres je rappelle n'y a pas d'heure
supplémentaire pour les cadres c'est
aussi la compensation pour ceux à qui on
a obligé et nous y avons consenti à
prendre des jours de congé pendant le
confinement
c'est une mesure juste parce qu'il faut
que chacun y contribue
mais quand je dis qu'il faut que chacun
y contribue il faut aussi que ceux qui
ont contribué à le maintien l'économie
il trouve ce juste salaire merci
monsieur rénale
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues j'ai du mal
à m'inscrire dans ce débat quoi et j'ai
du mal à vous comprendre le sujet vous
êtes en train de nous dire la première
ligne où la deuxième ligne vous évoquez
les caissières aurait donc dans une
période de confinement qui va durer un
mois et demi 5000 euros 5000 euros
d'heures supplémentaires si ça que vous
êtes en train de nous dire mais bien sûr
que si jusqu'à 5000 euros il n'y a pas
de difficultés donc c'est bien au dessus
de ce niveau que se situe
enfin quand même et c'est ça qui est
dans l'amendement
c'est ça que vous proposez le ministre
vous répond 95% des personnes concernées
sont exonérés 5% ne sont pas certains
non pas la première ligne et vous nous
convoquer et vous nous convoquer pour
des gens corps et 5000 euros
les gens qui nous écoutent là ils
doivent être ils doivent avoir les
cheveux qui est moi je n'ai plus
beaucoup mais quand même
5000 euros à un mois d'heures
supplémentaires mais de qui on parle de
qui parle-t-on et et vous nous convoquer
là et vous convoquez la justice sociale
mais au doucement on aura on va avoir
l'occasion la d'en parler de justice
sociale mais quand même je vous en prie
arrêtons arrêtons ce siècle
sincèrement la réponse du ministre est
bonne je vous le dis c'est comme ça dit
c'est couvert est en réalité la mesure
elle amène à finalement se priver de
charges patronales
c'est ça le sujet donc évoquer ce sujet
là et moi je vous dis charges patronales
on en a besoin surtout dans les
entreprises qui fonctionnent aujourd'hui
très bien et d'autre part cinq mille
euros c'est sa campagne question du jce
sociale ou je ne sais quoi
donc nous ne voterons pas cet amendement
nous sommes contre cet amendement
merci monsieur mais non ville
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre nous par contre nous voterons
donc l'amendement notre rapporteur
général
nous considérons que c'est une mesure de
justice et d'équité
merci merci chers collègues
monsieur le ministre souhaitait apporter
quelques précisions oui monsieur le
président à 4 précision ce que vous me
le permettez notamment pour répondre au
président retailleau et à ce qu'il
disait tout à l'heure c'est le président
vous savez mes propos lors de l'examen
promet du plfr 1
permettez-moi de compléter la citation
en rappelant que j'avais indiqué que si
le gouvernement était ouvert à une
discussion cela s'inscrivait dans le
cadre de mesures de relance non pas dans
le cadre de mesures d'urgence et nous
considérons que ce plfr de reste un
texte qui s'inscrit dans l'urgence je
voudrais ensuite a amené trois
précisions la première pour dire que
j'entends lorsque vous dites que la
prime prévue dans le secteur privé sur
insuffisante nous l'avons malgré tout
doublé dans son plafond puisque 2000
elle est passée à 2000 euros et nous
avons considérablement simplifier les
modalités de décisions d'octroi d'une
prime par les entreprises de manière à
ce que ce soit le plus rapide et le plus
facile possible pour les entreprises
la deuxième chose que je voulais
souligner mais monsieur rénald l'a fait
avec plus de verve que je ne le ferai
moi-même c'est de souligner à nouveau
que le dispositif tel qu'il existe
couvre 95 % de la population que les
métiers que vous avez cités pour papier
votre démonstration sont très largement
en deçà de cette limite de 5000 euros et
que la disposition que vous vous
proposer d'adopter ne modifierait en
rien leur situation seuls les salariés
relevant des 5% dépassant le plafond de
5000 euros seraient concernés si nous
appliquons si nous adoptions
l'amendement est par ailleurs le fait
d'exonérer les heures supplémentaires de
cotisation patronale n'aurait évidemment
aucun effet sur le niveau de
rémunération
des salariés concernés mais mais mais
monsieur le président otayo monsieur le
président votre taille aux jeunes dit
que que la limite la limite de quatre
jusqu'à la parole monsieur le ministre a
jugé lundi que j'indique au président un
retailleau que la limite de 95% que
j'évoque est bien calculé évalué sur une
année et que les dispositions proposées
par monsieur rapporteur s'applique à la
période de confinement dont je pense que
la vérité peut être partagée sur ce
point là par contre au delà du fait que
les cotisations patronales n'aurait pas
de d'effet sur la rémunération des
personnes et des métiers vous avez
évoqué je voudrais ajouter un troisième
et dernier point concernant les heures
supplémentaires dans la fonction
publique hospitalière
certains dispositifs ex effectivement
transitoire catégorielles mais je
voudrais souligner que en matière de
rémunération des heures supplémentaires
dans la fonction publique hospitalière
dans l'immense majorité des cas les
personnels sont appelés en règle
générale soit récupérée et souvent avec
difficulté les heures supplémentaires
soient les placer sur des comptes est
peinte en mai 1
la plupart du temps ces heures
supplémentaires ne sont pas payées
et c'est la raison pour laquelle le fait
de les rémunérer et les majorée de 50%
dans cette période peu est compatible
avec le plafond d'aidés 5000 euros j'ai
bien noté vous étiez pour c'est
compatible avec le plafond des 5000
euros et s'éteint un gain conséquent
financier pour les agents concernés
la ville reste défavorable merci
monsieur le ministre monsieur savoldelli
oui merci monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre le rapporteur général nous
le voterons pas
cet amendement malgré la déception de la
droite qui est pas à droite mais qui à
droite donc mon collègue qui a pu nous
l'aurions voter sur la défiscalisation
attendait mais l'amendement l'a bien lu
quand même personne donne de leçon à
d'aucuns ici voilà on l'a bien lu il y
avait la question de l'avenir
fiscalisation et on aurait pu le voter
au-delà de ces biens conviennent aux
réalités de ce qu'est le monde salarial
faut les faire les quatre cents euros
d'heures payées à payer on est bien
d'accord les 400 euros payés par mois
c'est pas si simple les avoirs bon dont
tu as qu'il y avait des fiscalisation
mais il ya un autre sujet mais là le
président retailleau franchement
cohérence bataille idéologique il nous a
parlé au premier projet de loi de
finances rectificatif et il me dira si
je me trompe
l'enjeu de la désocialisation et c'est
cette question idéologique et là dans
cet amendement il à la fois un
amendement d'urgence milana normande
après c'est normal le président
retailleau il un corpus il a et diallo
logique il a des concepts qu'il a une
pensée politique de la société et il
nous dit défiscalisation c'est des
choses qu'on connaît depuis un moment
mais il nous dit attends d exonération
des cotisations sociales
c'est ça la question et ça on peut pas
laisser passer
on peut pas laisser passer mes chers
collègues parce que fauquet cette
contribution
fauqué cette contribution et c'est pour
ça que oui et quand vous dit on verra
plus tard dans le débat pourquoi on pose
la question d'un collectif exceptionnel
sur le financement de la sécurité
sociale
parce que le débat il est là cela près
il est là ce matin parce qu'il y avait
trois branches on parle des ehpad mais
la sécurité sociale il ya la branche
vieillesse
puis à la branche maladie et ya la
branche retraite donc les débats qu'on a
là en filigrane sur peut-être des
amendements qui correspondent en volume
financier à des volumes qui sont pas
énormes
il recouvre un autre débat dans la
société donc voilà avec ses explications
là vous comprendrez que nous ne voterons
pas cet amendement merci cher collègue
monsieur rapporteur souhaitait aussi
apporter quelques précisions
je vais pas interpréter l'après et la
bourse et du préau retailleau
par contre je sais interpréter mon
amendement mon amendement stade
amendements que limité à la crise
sanitaire pendant ces temps de crise
sanitaire il n'y a pas de débat sur les
heures supplémentaires en général vous
avez à l'heure actuelle et actes du
droit à forfait de 5000 euros par an par
an dans laquelle vous avez une
exonération d'impôt sur le revenu des
heures supplémentaires et l'amendement
c'est une exonération de cotisations
sociales salariales et patronales et
d'impôt sur le revenu pendant la seule
période de crise sanitaire
-plus de conclusion et quant aux
vêtements ça se combine avec les 5000
euros de est alors pourquoi vous peut
être
on peut avoir un débat sur le fait
faut-il exonérer les prédications
patronale de ce qui fait semblant de
débat oui je le pense tous ces dossiers
une incitation tout simplement pour les
entreprises à verser des heures
supplémentaires voilà donc pour le
salarié ils y trouvent un intérêt mais
pour l'entreprise ça aussitôt si
l'entreprise vers 6 heures
supplémentaires donc je pense que c'est
un dispositif qui doit être encouragée
dans la situation actuelle
merci monsieur la portière monsieur
segouin votre amendement est retiré au
profit de celui de la commission
donc le 44e tirés dont je mets aux voix
à l'amendement de la commission le 203
avec un avis défavorable du gouvernement
qui et pour qui et contre qui s'abstient
il est adopté
nous passons à l'amendement 280 monsieur
savoldelli merci le ministre monsieur le
rapporteur général
pour ma part ma collègue marie noëlle
lienemann ont été bien plus en capacité
en efficience de d'expliquer cet
amendement néanmoins c'est un amendement
d'appel
voilà faut il faut le dire pour l'avoir
l'humidité
c'est un amendement d'appel pour essayer
de se projeter plus tôt dans la presse
faut être honnête sur la question la
survalorisation immobilière et j'attire
l'attention donc on pourra leur retirer
mais si vous pouviez nous dira un peu
quelque chose monsieur le ministre sur
cette question là c'est à dire que nous
craignons qu'à une survalorisation
immobilière dans le cadre d'acquisitions
deux salariés de gens modestes mais qui
veut la voile à acquérir et on peut
penser que dans le moment de doute et
d'inquiétude qui à leur tour à la pierre
peut être quand même une question qui
remet de l'assurance way chez les gens
et il ya une autre question aussi c'est
qu'il peut y avoir aussi une
survalorisation immobilières pour les
entreprises et malheureusement j'ai
tendance à penser ça je peux me tromper
mais on va avoir des chefs d'entreprise
des gens qui ont l'esprit d'entreprendre
qui avait telle ou telle activité
économique qui vont changer d'activités
économiques qui vont se réorienter donc
ils vont être en situation peut-être
d'avoir des beaux des loyers pour
l'activité de l'ortt et leur petite
entreprise mais peut-être qu'ils vont
aussi acheter donc voilà c'est pour
attirer votre attention sur
d'éventuelles survalorisation de
l'immobilier merci merci monsieur à
porter ça veut délicatement ya pas de
survalorisation pascal pas de
transaction du tout voilà donc à ce
moment c'est n'y a pas de notaire il n'y
a pas de vide agences immobilières il
n'y a aucun acte notarié donc par la
période de crise c'est très difficile
d'aller constater une éventuelle sur le
valorise sur des cris et nul ne sait
quelle sera l'évolution du marché
immobilier dans l'avenir est ce que il y
aura une restriction du crédit mobilier
c'est une hypothèse est ce que les prix
vont se maintenir est ce que le marché
immobilier va voir une correction comme
c'est le cas souvent dans les périodes
de crise la baisse du pouvoir d'achat
les difficultés des entreprises etc tout
ça ne court pas spécialement à une
augmentation des prix de l'immobilier
bon voilà dans tous les cas en ce moment
ça me paraît être totalement hors de
propos
il n'y a aucune transaction immobilière
donc c'est certainement pas le moment
d'assurer une contribution virtuel donc
je pense que tu as un amendement d'appel
qui n'a pas sa place dans un texte
d'urgence donc demande de retrait si nos
avis défavorable merci à mathieu
ministre le président je partage le
constat fait par le rapporteur sur
l'absence ou quasiment l'absence de
transactions à tel point que nous avons
même prévu de dématérialiser une partie
des procédures notamment des signatures
d'actes mais malgré cela le niveau du
marché reste très bas donc le le risque
vous craignez n'est pas constatée à date
le moment vous présentez vous même comme
un amendement d'appel et peut-être aussi
un appel à la vigilance sur ce sujet
pour voir en fonction des évolutions
plus on ne peut prévoir à ce stade
de l'évolution du marché de l'immobilier
si de tels risques apparaissait et
quelles mesures devraient être prises
dans ce cas là à date il n'y en a pas
donc je m'associe à la demande de
retrait que j'écris pressentir chez
monsieur d'alliés pour explication de
vote
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
je pense que le moment va être retirée
moi j'étais un peu surpris de la
présentation par notre collègue
savoldelli parce que l'amendement
d'appel je pensais qu'il consistait à
pointer la situation dans laquelle
certains bailleurs sociaux vont
peut-être se trouvait à l'issue de cette
crise puisque dans l'objet vous disiez
que la taxe en question effectivement
dans le contexte je pense qu'elle n'est
pas très opportune du tout mais devrait
aller aux bailleurs sociaux qui
pourraient se trouver en difficulté
je pense qu'on va avoir là un vrai sujet
dans certains territoires ans bien
évidemment la seine saint denis mais
peut-être à d'autres
certains bailleurs sociaux vont être à
nouveau impacté par les effets de cette
crise certaines familles vont se trouver
en difficulté pour le paiement des
loyers et il va donc y avoir un vrai
sujet auquel nous devrions réfléchir
alors c'est pas dans ce pays est fermée
je pense que dans un prochain texte il
faudra regarder à nouveau la situation
des bailleurs sociaux qui ont été très
impacté par les mesures décidées par le
gouvernement et donc il va y avoir
effectivement un vrai sujet et j'en
profite je fais une incidente monsieur
le président je pense que vous me le
pardonnerai sur le ministre lors de la
réunion de la commission en
visioconférence je vous avais interrogé
sur la réforme des apl elle a été
repoussée c'était 1er avril là je pense
que ce sera pas en application 2020 et
j'avais attiré votre attention sur le
fait qu'il allait manquer un milliard de
au final et vous m'avez répondu en
commission qu'il n'y a pas d'impact 2020
on verrait ça les prochaines mais si
monsieur le ministre il ya un impact
2010 mais s'il ya un impact 2020 puisque
les crédits inscrits prenez en compte
effectivement l'économique la réforme
apportait alors si alors vraiment on a
un vrai désaccord là dessus donc tout
cela pour dire que un certain nombre de
bailleurs vont se trouver à moins
en difficulté sur le final j'aimerais
entendre votre point venu parce que les
crédits budgétaires à mon sens n'y sont
pas et puis là aussi il va y avoir
certainement beaucoup plus de
bénéficiaires de l'apl pour ceux dont la
situation pourrait se dégrader
merci allez monsieur mise même si on est
un petit peu hors sujet mais bon hein
monsieur le président pour dire à
monsieur le sénateur d'allier que peut
être ai je manqué de clarté en
commission mais ce que j'ai répondu à
votre question était en deux points
le premier pour dire qu il nous
paraissait trop tôt à ce stade pour
acter un report de la réforme appel au
delà de 2020 mais pour confirmer votre
analyse sur le fait qu' un report ou un
report au delà de 2020 aurait des
conséquences sur le talent et qu'il
faudrait en tirer les conséquences et
les conclusions je ne vais pas nier
l'impact sur 2020 en cas de report jeu
gérald darmanin a eu l'occasion de dire
qu'il y aurait d'autres textes
financiers peut-être même si la
situation devait durer ou évoluer un bel
fr3 peut-être sont-ils alors l'occasion
de régler cette question là mais je
n'avais pas reporter l'échéance à 2020
monsieur monsieur savoldelli p merci
monsieur le président quand je l'avais
dit c'est un amendement d'appel
donc nous allons le retirer puisque
après ensuite dans le dos le déroulé il
y aura des amendements d'ailleurs qui
viennent de de plusieurs groupes sur la
question de la difficulté pour un
certain nombre de nos concitoyens de
s'acquitter de leur loyer
hélas ce que dit philippe dallier moi
j'ai un point de convergence 1 et il le
sait on vit la même chose c'est qu'il va
y avoir il va ya un bon nombre de nan
mais sérieusement bon nombre de familles
qui vont avoir des difficultés voyez
pour payer leur loyer et il ya des
bailleurs sociaux qui n'ont pas tous la
même structure financière et sa philippe
dallier le sais comme moi il y en a qui
vont avoir la capacité de pouvoir la
volonté et la capacité voiliers de
reporter sur plusieurs mois
ça se fait dans d'autres pays j'ai vu au
portugal j'ai vu dans d'autres pays
européens mais il ya d'autres bailleurs
sociaux qui vont pas avoir les
trésoreries la capacité de tenir donc
voilà on le retire
mais je pense que voilà ce débat va
revenir et c'est pour attirer
l'attention de l'exécutif aussi
nationales merci merci chers collègues
trois amendements identiques tout
d'abord le 6 c'est monsieur o
oui amendements proposés à l'initiative
de nathalie goulet qui propose qu'à
l'image de certains pays comme le
danemark
il est proposé de priver toute
entreprise dans un paradis fiscal de
bénéficier de mesures des demies en
place par l'état dans le cadre de l'état
d'urgence
ça concerne l'ensemble des aides du plfr
et tous les dispositifs tels que le
chômage partiel
merci chers collègues l'amendement 221
c'est monsieur cap hume
c'est un amendement qui va dans le même
sens que celui présenté par un collègue
l'eau il saïd et qui va me réconcilier
également avec mon collègue savoldelli
évoqué puisque il est également
identique à celui des communistes
comme quoi on peut être de droite et
avoir des idées généreuses et de la
morale donc l'idée elle être extrêmement
simple
adepte pour les pour les sociétés qui
ont un établissement ou une filiale dans
un paradis fiscal
merci monsieur savoldelli le 301
oui merci monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre monsieur le directeur
monsieur le rapporteur général
je peux vous mettre directeur général
aussi il ya un peu de fatigue
ça a été le cas hier soir c'est vrai que
sur cet amendement on devrait retrouver
l'unanimité du sénat
et là ça sera une aide y compris aux
négociations qu'à la france vis-à-vis
des paradis fiscaux des gaffes a envoyé
deux quand même tous ces paradis fiscaux
cette évasion d'argent donc vraiment
nous sommes dans le même esprit que les
deux autres amendements déposés et là on
pourrait avoir l'unanimité du sénat ce
qui permettra j'ai vu qui hier il paraît
qu'on s'attaquait au manque du budget
voté par l'assemblée nationale
là ça serait vraiment bien parce que
celui-là il sera très significatif
merci monsieur le rapporteur l'avis de
la commission sur ces trois amendements
identiques nous paraissent un peu être
symbolique
ce que concrètement vous visez quel
dispositif vous visez à travers
l'article 1 et 1 bis vous visez
notamment le fonds de solidarité et le
abyss la déductibilité des abandons de
créances
donc ça veut dire concrètement le fonds
de solidarité c'est la bonne
fonctionnalité je rappelle ce sont des
entreprises qui ont moins d'un million
de chf euros de chiffre d'affaires et
moi de 10 salariés dont vraiment des tpe
c'est quoi c'est le club a recensé
l'artisan c'est le travailleur
indépendant et il faudrait qu'il a une
filiale dans un hôtel c'est dans les
filets dans les états et territoires non
coopératifs
c'est à dire que parler vrai que le
commerçant une filiale à andillac
seychelles au venait tout aux fidji sur
l'île de guam sur aux samoa américaines
asamoah trinitad et tobago
donc je doute que le boucher charcutier
qui a besoin en ce moment de l'aide de
l'état et du fonds de solidarité ou le
commerce qui est actuellement fermé où
le restaurant est une filiale dans les
samoa au l'île de guam donc je pense que
c'est ça me paraît être un peu un peu
sur abandon alors peut-être qu'il ya
aussi dispositif supplémentaire bon je
sais pas moins que le gouvenement une
autre appréciation mais en visant
l'article 1 et 1 bis je pense que ça me
paraît exposer les artisans est les tpe
une situation qui ne risque pas d
exister ok purement théorique du moins
merci donc c'est un avis défavorable
monsieur le ministre merci à monsieur le
président je partage l'avis du
rapporteur sur le caractère extrêmement
limité de la portée des amendements qui
sont proposés pour les mêmes arguments
puisqu'il faudrait que des entreprises
éligibles au dispositif présenté et des
filiales ou des associations avec des
entreprises dans des territoires non
coopératifs par ailleurs l'amendement
qui est que vous avez bien voulu adopter
tout à l'heure proposée par le
gouvernement qui vient clarifier la
rédaction de l'article adopté par
l'assemblée nationale sur la déduction
fiscale et la neutralité fiscale des
loyers qui ne seraient pas versées
restreint déjà le champ d'application
est vilain limiter les risques que vous
soulevez dans l'amendement j'ajoute que
la rédaction vous propose et porte aussi
un risque sinon de confusion en tout cas
de difficultés pour des entreprises qui
légitimement pourrait bénéficier de cet
abandon de créance d'y renoncer pour des
raisons que vous ne poursuivez pas
puisque nous parlons que des petites
entreprises est de celles qui
rencontrent des difficultés donc c'est
une demande de retrait ou à défaut
d'avis des favoris merci monsieur
n'auront pas l'explication de vote
oui alors peut-être qu'il ya un petit
problème rédactionnelle mais ce sont
toutes les aides à toutes les
entreprises
dans cette période et je veux dire
restreindre effectivement le principe de
ne pas aider les entreprises qui ont des
ramifications dans les paradis fiscaux
est un principe qu'il faudrait retenir
systématiquement pour toutes les aides
prévues par l'état et la loi de finances
merci chers collègues
monsieur k plus on en avait déjà discuté
en discuter en commission des finances
donc effectivement
à prime abord de toute façon ça exclut
toutes les tpe de type plomberie
charcutiers bouchers qui eux par
définition ne sont pas concernées par
l'amendement puisqu'ils n'ont pas de
filiales ou d'établissements dans un
paradis fiscal
donc ne sont pas touchés il faut se
rassurer donc c'est effectivement un
amendement extrêmement symbolique pour
les sociétés qui auraient un
établissement dans un paradis fiscal et
en réfléchissant c'est pas totalement
exclue parce que par définition le la
société de l'état la filiale
établissements dans un paradis fiscal
c'est une boîte aux lettres ozil ou âme
ou dans une boîte à lettres mais pas
beaucoup de salariés donc il ya par
définition moins de 10 salariés dans une
filiale dans un paradis fiscal puisque
c'est d'une boîte aux lettres donc il
sait pas totalement exclu que des
sociétés fictives des sociétés coquilles
existe et puisse demander des aides
alors qu'ils sont à moins de 10 salariés
je dirais même par définition donc et je
partage également l'analyse de piano il
ya peut-être un petit problème
rédactionnel dans le sens où faudrait qu
il peut être pas viser seulement leur
l'article 1er est l'article 1er bis mais
par définition il me semble pas que les
sociétés qui font qu'ils sont inscrits
dans un établissement fin qui attire
établissent un établi une filiale dans
un paradis fiscal soit des sociétés de
plus de 10 salariés
merci chers collègues donc je mets aux
voix monsieur le rapporteur
juste un petit problème d'accès simple
amendement est totalement inopérant il
vise clairement le fonds de solidarité
deuxièmement les créances des baux les
fameuses créances la garantie l'abandon
de créance pour les bailleurs donc les
baux commerciaux
le chômage partiel n'est pas visée parce
que je mâche martial encore une fois
dans la loi de finances le premier plfr
on avait couvert les crédits c'est une
ordonnance donc voilà donc très
concrètement on est en train d'inventer
espèces du sinn agace juridique pour un
fonds de solidarité je rappelle 2500
euros voilà donc ce que c'est ça qui
fait que l'amendement vise donc
donc je vous invite je comprend l'esprit
mais je pense que la rédaction doit être
totalement revue parce qu'encore une
fois votre quelque chose qui est
normatif
si vous voulez viser les grandes
entreprises la garantie de l'état et
autres c'est un autre amendement
d'autres textes pour le faire mais là on
vise bien le fonds de solidarité qu'est
de 1500 euros là peut-être que j'entends
une coquille vide n'a pas forcément
besoin de salariés pour faire moins de
re d'un million d'euros de chiffre
d'affaires en france est donc très
concrètement et pour avoir un fond de
solidarité
je rappelle il faut cette obligation
être résident fiscal en france c'est une
autre obligation dans le texte voilà
donc je pense que c'était on est sur un
plus une pétition de principe qu'un
abonnement opérationnel merci monsieur
le rapporteur après ces précisions du
rapporteur est ce que les amendements
sont maintenus monsieur lourds est
maintenue monsieur capus est maintenue
aussi donc je l'aimais aux voix je mets
aux voix les amendements 6 221 et 301
identique avec deux avis défavorables de
la commission et du gouvernement qui est
pour lever bien la main
alors attendez lever bien la main parce
que là sinon on va pas on va pas pouvoir
compter
qui est contre
qui s'abstient ils sont adoptés
nous passons à l'article 1er terre cinq
amendements en discussion commune le 288
c'est monsieur guay pardon il ya des
prises de paroles pardon monsieur
rapporteur rôle parce que nous avons
encore de 134 amendements à examiner
nous avons plusieurs amendements qui
porte sur le même sujet je voudrais que
les collègues comprennent l'enjeu tout
simplement sa porte sur la tva réduit
sur les moyens de protection dans les
lits contre l'épidémie
donc vous savez que l'assemblée
nationale a prévu un taux de tva 5,5
pour les masques et pour les gels
hydroalcooliques donc ça s'était fait
par le texte qui nous est transmis par
nos collègues députés et vous avez à sa
demande d'amendement qui soit réduisent
tôt soit exonère catho de 2,1 soit
exonère je précise tout de suite que j'y
serais défavorable pour une raison
simple passe des vins rab sur le
principe mais c'est tout simplement
contraire à la directive tva
nous avons le droit de faire un taux à
5,5 n'envoie pas le droit d'exonérer ou
de fer atoa d'un doctorat que demain
tous les amendements qui prévoient des
taux à zéro ne soit pas opérationnel en
tous les cas ne sont pas contraire à la
directive
quant aux autres amendements il y en a
un certain nombre qui est temps de
laisser les taux de tva réduit de 5,5
non seulement aux jeunes mais également
tenues de protection là par définition
j'y suis favorable de la commission un
amendement dans ce sens
un amendement qui d'ailleurs reprend une
des suggestions du gouvernement près de
rédactionnel donc l'amendement de la
commission devrait couvrir l'ensemble
des dieux du champ des mois une
protection
ça veut dire les masques bien sûr qu'ils
sont déjà couverts les gels et pas
simplement les gels hydroalcooliques il
y à d'autres types de gel ou de produits
de produits de qui permet de lutter
contre l'épidémie la provocation libye
et bien sûr tous les moyens de
protection les taux de protection
c'est ce sont les blues les surblouse
les charlottes médical etc
pourquoi parce que monsieur ministre je
le dis davance si vous avez un grand
nombre d'amendements ce sont les
matériels qui aujourd'hui manque
cruellement encore aujourd'hui dans les
ehpad dans les services de soins à
domicile etc etc sur les masques ont eu
souvent le débat mais les surblouse les
blues et charlotte sont des baisses des
produits qui sont extrêmement difficiles
que les collectivités sont produits
achetés et qui sont notamment dans les
ehpad très difficile à obtenir donc il
est important que ce que ca chaude qui
sont de première nécessité soient
encouragés j'en profite pour présenter
l'amendement comme ça je devrais défendu
tout à l'heure je précise que si on
appris le mot tenue de protection
c'est parce que c' est le terme qui est
employé dans le rescrit fiscal du 7
avril 2020 donc c'est le propre terme de
bercy vous avez un rescrit fiscal qui
indique la liste des produits exonérés
de tva suite à un don et il emploie le
terme tenue de protection donc c'est
opérationnel c'est votre propre terme
ces étapes de bercy nous voilà donc à la
su si l'amendement la commission
auxquelles je vous demande de vous
rallier est votée nous aurons un
dispostif complet pas tva à 5,5 sur les
sur les gels y compris des alcooliques
mais pas seulement
tva réduit sur les masques étaient
venues et tva réduit sur l'ensemble des
tenues de protection donc c'est la
raison pour laquelle je voudrais que les
collègues sont fasse pas trop long débat
ils sont satisfaits par l'amendement 204
de la commission des finances
merci monsieur le rapporteur mme adama
président de prima merci monsieur le
président mes chers collègues puisque
nous abordons dans cet article des
équipements de sécurité
je souhaiterais attirer votre attention
monsieur le ministre sur un sujet qui me
semble cruciale pour la réussite de la
reprise cruciale et sensible c'est celui
de la responsabilité des chefs
d'entreprise vous avez proposé nous la
voterons une boîte à outils
gouvernementale avec beaucoup de mesures
qui sont bienvenus
les mesures en faveur de la demande de
l'offre et d'investissement mais ces
mesures à notre sens n'auront que peu
d'effet si vous ne clarifier pas les
conditions sanitaires et juridiques de
la reprise cette crise n'est pas une
crise économique classique elle est à la
base sanitaires et si nous ne sécurisons
pas plus clairement les chefs
d'entreprises pour leur indiquer
jusqu'où va leurs responsabilités
vis-à-vis des salariés en matière
sanitaire
nous créerons une incertitude qui va
constituer pour les chefs d'entreprise
comme pour les salariés un frein majeur
à la reprise la situation aujourd'hui
n'est pas clair le code du travail dit
obligation de moyens mais la
jurisprudence oscille entre obligation
de résultat et obligation de moyens les
inspections du travail ont leur
interprétation
les directs ont la leur les syndicats et
les salariés sont naturellement inquiets
et on ne peut pas les blâmer bien
évidemment et par conséquent les chefs
d'entreprise le sont aussi
il faut naturellement protéger les
salariés
mais jusqu'où peut-on imputer un chef
d'entreprise la diffusion de l'épidémie
parmi ses salariés
jusqu'où précisément va sa
responsabilité en matière de fourniture
de masques de gants de blues etc
ce sont à ces questions qui ont trait à
la confiance qu'il faut répondre
précisément c'est un sujet sensible car
il n'est absolument pas question de
brader la sécurité sanitaire des
salariés mais ce sujet à mon avis ne
peut être mis sous le tapis de peur de
tension il faut trouver ensemble des
solutions de réassurance
il faut sécuriser les salariés je le
répète il faut sécuriser les chefs
d'entreprise qui engage je le répète
leur responsabilité pénale
cette clarification contrat à mon sens
autant que les milliards que nous
mettons sur la table et nous sommes à
votre disposition à celle de madame la
ministre du travail pour réfléchir sur
les outils de cette nécessaire
sécurisation juridique
merci merci madame espagnac vous
souhaitiez prend la parole oui monsieur
le président merci je saisis parole sur
article pour prendre la parole et faire
une adresse gouvernement nous avions été
plusieurs sur ses mandats demande
la baisse de tva 5,5 et notamment notre
modèle et moi-même ce sur les produits
de protection et de premiers signes
notamment les masques mais je voudrais
alerté le gouvernement en tout cas faire
une demande une requête qui est certes
compliquée qui est en plus de baisses de
thé vert beaucoup aujourd'hui deux chefs
d'entreprise voire même de particuliers
nous demande tout simplement que le prix
des masques soit plafonné plafonné
pourquoi parce que indéniablement que ce
soit aujourd'hui enfin certes des
collectivités mettent à disposition des
citoyens des masques mais demain
évidemment la protection de tous est
nécessaire et on voit sur les réseaux
sociaux dans les magasins beaucoup de
prix qui montent de façon inacceptable
or encore une fois il s'agit de la
protection de concitoyens alors monsieur
le ministre vous allez me dire c'est
compliqué puisque il s'agit aussi
évidemment l'importation est donc
compliqué de limiter le prix d'une
importation mais pour autant je crois
que pour la protection de nos
concitoyens ainsi que pour les
entreprises qui encore une fois ceci
génère un coût souvent et il est normal
en tout cas qu'elles veulent elles aussi
à la protection de leurs travailleurs
il n'est pas possible de continuer à
voir cette inflation du prix du masque
et encore une fois je crois qu'il faut
qu'on arrive à travailler ensemble ça a
été fait pour le gel et je ne
comprendrais pas aujourd'hui que nous
puissions pas le faire aujourd'hui en
france pour les masquer merci le
président otayo souhaitait prendre la
parole aussi très brièvement
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
président ce que ce que vient d'évoquer
la présidente sophie primas est
fondamentale les conditions de la
relance d'une reprise dépendront - des
tombeaux de milliards d'euros que nous
déverseront sur l'économie que les
conditions de la crise de la coupe de la
confiance que nous pourrons recréer en
clair nous voulons absolument préserver
la sécurité la protection sanitaire des
salariés mais monsieur le ministre un
point doit être tranchée souvent madame
pénicaud lorsque nous l'interrogions
nous disait non mais les choses sont
claires la loi est claire la loi dispose
que le chef d'entreprise a une
obligation est uniquement une obligation
de moyens elle n'a pas tort mais elle
n'a pas non plus eu raison puisque la
construction prétorienne des tribunaux
disposent que le juge considère que
chef d'entreprise le plus souvent à une
obligation n'ont pas de moyens mais de
résultats
c'est absolument fondamental pour que
des secteurs d'activité puissent
reprendre
et évidemment on ne peut pas déposer
aujourd'hui sur ce type de véhicule
initiative un amendement mais
pouvez-vous d'ores et déjà monsieur le
ministre nous répondre est ce que oui ou
non le gouvernement entend trancher le
conflit qu'il y a entre ce que le
législateur a inscrit dans la loi
est ce que par ailleurs la jurisprudence
inscrit dans cette construction
prétorienne du droit social
il nous faut absolument une réponse
claire et précise que contient le
gouvernement merci monsieur guay sur le
président monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues je n'avais pas prévu
d'intervenir mais c'est sur cette
question de dans quelles conditions les
salariés puissent peuvent reprendre le
travail
il ya évidemment la question
l'obligation de moyens ou de résultats
je vais y revenir mais la première
obligation c'est que les conditions
sanitaires soient respectés c'est ça la
vraie question est qu'est du masque
dégel
voilà la première des conditions et
ensuite vient le débat pour que les
chantiers par youtube par exemple
puissent reprendre
puisqu'il ya eu la rédaction du guide
pratique on en a beaucoup parlé mais y
compris les organisations patronales
puisque nous en avons beaucoup
auditionné dans le cadre de nos groupes
de travail de suivi y compris par
exemple la capeb dit que mettre en place
le guide pratique dans la réalité c'est
quasiment impossible parce que un camion
ou un véhicule par ouvriers pour y aller
c'est impossible
respectez les gestes barrière de 1 mètre
sur un chantier c'est impossible et le
surcoût par ouvrier du bâtiment
aujourd'hui pour avoir les blues les
masques etc
ces 40 euros par jour et par ouvrier
voilà la réalité
et donc beaucoup d'entrepreneurs font le
choix de ne pas reprendre en plus on y
ajoute la question de la main d'oeuvre
parce que certains sont malades autres
en garde d'enfants la question de
l'interconnexion entre professions
certains sont au travail d'autres pas et
sur les chantiers ça ralentit et la
dernière question c'est
l'approvisionnement matériaux en
matériaux mais sur l'obligation ensuite
de moyens ou de résultats moi je le
redis ça fait madame prima on a beaucoup
discuté de ça les caisses derniers jours
le gouvernement peut dire ce qu'il veut
ça ne pourra pas puisque il dit
obligation de moyens mais en réalité et
vous le savez la jurisprudence a tranché
sur l'obligation de résultat et personne
ne pourra le garantir sur cette question
et moi je le dis parce que je l' ai
entendu j'ai pas dis ici mais je l'aï
entendu pendant les groupes de travail
il faut assouplir un peu le code du
travail ou dire à l'inspection du
travail de mettre un peu la douce
nous nous refusons ça dans le moment de
crise dans laquelle nous sommes
l'inspection du travail doit faire son
travail et ne peut pas être sanctionnée
pour faire son travail et respecter le
droit des salariés
donc si essentiels nécessaires ne sont
pas réunies alors on ne peut pas
reprendre le travail mais les chantiers
merci mais la vraie question c'est les
conditions nécessaires merci chers
collègues
merci chers collègues donc nous allons
passer aux amendements
madame taille et polluant pardon merci
monsieur le monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
je ne n'avais pas prévu d'intervenir non
plus sur cette question en tout cas pas
forcément maintenant mais je voudrais
rappeler enfin rajouté en complément de
ce que ce que vient de dire notre
collègue est et dans la discussion qui
est qui est actuellement la nôtre
effectivement il y a quand même un
véritable problème avec des injonctions
qui sont paradoxal puisque on a d'un
côté un ministre une ministre du travail
qui dit la protection des salariés est
la priorité absolue
mais d'un autre côté et elle renvoie
donc les
et les chefs d'entreprise à l'obligation
d'appliquer finalement les guides de
bonnes pratiques dont on sait très bien
et ça a été très bien expliquée par
monsieur guay qui ne sont pas forcément
tous applicable qui n'est pas forcément
facile
on n'arrête pas d'en discuter d'obtenir
les masques etc
mais elle dit quand même protection et
en même temps il y a un certain nombre
deux circulaires de deux textes qui ont
été envoyés à l'inspection du travail
d'empêchement d'un certain nombre
d'inspecteurs du travail et il ya à ce
sujet une situation qui fait grand bruit
aujourd'hui dans la marne
on voit bien que l'on demande aux
inspecteurs du travail de mettre la
douce
alors on ne peut pas d'un côté dire en
audition au sénat ou ailleurs notre
priorité absolue c'est la protection des
salariés dans le cadre de leur travail
et d'un autre côté être dans le fait que
les entre dans le fait de ne fait que
constater que la plupart ou un certain
nombre d'entreprises ne peuvent pas
mettre ces moyens-là et de dire à
l'inspection du travail
finalement douce il y à un moment
donné un moment où le ministère du
travail doit être clair à notre sens à
mon sens il est extrêmement important de
dire que oui la protection des salariés
doit être appliquée sinon tout ce que
nous faisons sur le confinement ne sert
à rien et les prérogatives des
inspecteurs du travail doivent être
confortées et ne doivent pas avoir le
sentiment qui se répand qu'ils sont dans
un moment où on cherche à les empêcher
de faire leur travail
merci chers collègues donc nous passons
à l'examen de cinq amendements
discussion commune 288 monsieur
savoldelli hung savoldelli peut-être
présenté le 2 188 l310 je sens qu'on va
être d'accord monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
rapporteur général
là on a quatre amendements qui
s'emboîtent avec nos collègues du groupe
rdse au fond la même proposition que
nous c'est qu'est exonération complète
c'est-à-dire on prend le chemin qu'a
pris l'assemblée nationale
kbc à 5,5 la tva et moi je me félicite
de cette décision à l'assemblée
nationale et notre collègue du groupe
airness comme nous on propose
l'exonération ça c'est trois amendements
sur les quatre donc donc et celui de
monsieur le rapporteur général qui lui
élargi le dispositif aux tenues de
protection c'est à dire qu'il ya pas que
masquer gel et le rapporteur général
propose d'élargir à l'ensemble des
dispositifs de sécurité de sécurisation
des tenues ça on peut que le partager
donc moi je pense faut qu'on trouve un
compromis là sur cette question là parce
que ça va être valable pour les
entreprises qu'acquiert des masques des
gels et des tenues de protection mais ça
va être vrai aussi pour les
collectivités territoriales
donc voilà - chemin disposition notre
amendement en lien avec celui du
rapporteur général c'est à dire est-ce
qu'on peut pas trouver un compromis ici
un on élargit à tous les dispositifs ce
que dit rapporteur général et on baisse
encore la tva on la passe de 5,5 à 2 1
c'est à dire qu'on va pas à zéro parce
qu'on va avoir le droit communautaire et
toute une argumentation qui valent
refusé on le passe à 2 1 là on fait un
geste concret on baisse encore un petit
peu la tva de la valeur ajoutée ça va
être un signe encourageant à la fois
pour les entreprises qui vont avoir des
charges importantes vis-à-vis des
dispositifs de sécurité
et c'est vrai aussi pour les
collectivités territoriales qui font
aussi l'effet kiss cool c'est qu'à la
fois faut qu'on assure la protection de
nos agents et la sécurisation des agents
de la fonction publique territoriale
comme ceux de l'état évidemment mais
faut aussi qu'on assure la protection la
sécurité de nos populations
voilà ce qu'on a ce qu'on met à votre
disposition mais mes chers collègues
merci chers collègues donc le 264 et 263
madame de l'autre écoutez jeu mais ceux
ci complètement au nom de jean marc
gabouty qui devait présenter ses
amendements à la demande de monsieur ben
ok nous partageons cette demande
merci le rapporteur a déjà présenté son
amendement donc monsieur le ministre sur
ces cinq amendements
merci monsieur le président sur les
amendements autre que celui de monsieur
le rapporteur je partage
les arguments qui ont été évoqués par
monsieur le rapporteur est donc
essentiellement pour des questions de
forme l'avis défavorable sur
l'amendement de monsieur le rapporteur
général
nous avons une difficulté parce qu'à
notre sens les équipements de protection
tels que mentionnés nous paraissent ne
pas entrer dans le champ des produits
pharmaceutiques et nous pourrions avoir
une difficulté avec le droit
communautaire c'est ce qui m'amène à
donner un avis défavorable mais
peut-être que cette question peut être
creuser approfondi dit si la cmp ou dans
le cas de la navette parlementaire donc
l'avis défavorable sur tous les
amendements pour répondre à
l'interpellation de monsieur le
président retailleau et et de madame la
présidente
c'est un sujet qui est évidemment un
sujet majeur nous devons accompagner
dans le cadre de ce qu'on appelle
peut-être de manière un peu trop d'angle
augmente parfois le plan de
déconfinement la reprise d'activité dans
le secteur privé comme dans le secteur
public et dans sur ce sujet comme sur
d'autres
nous savons qu'il ya parfois une
différence comme vous l'avez souligné
entre le droit tel qu'il a été écrit par
le législateur et la jurisprudence qui a
été construite par les différentes
juridictions quel que soit d'ailleurs la
nature du droit et des sujets tranché
c'est un point d'attention du ministère
du travail et du ministère de l'économie
puisque il faut que tu puisses y ont
veillé à conjuguer à la fois la
protection des salariés la protection
des agents publics vous me permettez
d'élargir systématiquement au secteur
public et cette possibilité de reprise
dans des conditions qui soient les
meilleures possibles pour l'ensemble de
notre économie et l'ensemble de notre
système productif
je sais que mes deux collègues qui
travaillent ardemment et la présentation
des modalités de déconfinement pour
reprendre cette expression dans le chef
du gouvernement dans quelques jours
maintenant nous permettra d'ici
selon les proposée par le président la
république d'aborder ces sujets là je
note vos interventions et celles des
autres parlementaires sur le même sujet
comme autant de contributions et point
d' alerte
c'est un point d'attention nous
partageons et sur lequel nous allons
nous pencher dans les jours qui viennent
merci monsieur le rapporteur tous ses
amendements vont dans le sens j'ai bien
entendu ce qu'a dit notre collègue s'est
levé délit qui souhaitent aller dans le
même sens
le jeu serait très favorable à ces
amendements si c'était possible
malheureusement
la directive communautaire interdite
l'exonération de tva est interdite le
taux à 2 1
votto un dispositif qui est opérationnel
le seul dispositif opérationnel ses bras
taux à 5,5
je n'ai pas rédigé la directive
communautaire mais l'honnêteté doit nous
conduire à voter un dispositif qui soit
compatible donc c'est la raison pour
laquelle je demande aide à vouloir bien
vous rallié à l'amendement de 104 la
commission des finances qui va être
appelé leurs priorités
alors c'est une demande de priorités de
la commission donc dont je suis saisi l
est de droit sauf opposition du
gouvernement est ce que le gouvernement
est d'accord pour que on va te
prioritairement sur le 204 donc la
priorité est accordée
donc nous votons sur l'amendement 204 de
la commission pardon monsieur richard
pour explication de vote
monsieur le président je voudrais tout
de même suggéré au rapporteur général
le rappel d'un précédent qui portait sur
l'abaissement exceptionnelle du taux de
tva sur un domaine de communication il
me semble bien que c'était la presse en
ligne ou le parlement en bousculant un
peu le droit communautaire a anticipé
une baisse qui n'était pas dans la liste
fermée adoptée par le parlement
européenne et où plusieurs gouvernements
ont obtenu dans les semaines qui suivent
et que le cette rubrique soit ajouté à
la liste
il me semble que dans un pays où nous
pratiquons y la tva à 2,1 sur les biens
médicaux
le fait d'y ajouter les biens de
protection de la personne dans une
période de crise épidémique n'est pas un
gros écart brap au droit de l'union et
que si notre gouvernement présente une
demande d'extension à cet objet là
devant la commission je serais bien
étonné qui est pas un nombre
significatif de gouvernement d'union qui
partagent le même souci puisque c'est
une des sociétés qui ça
tu va s'imposer dans l'ensemble de
l'europe merci cher collègue monsieur
savoldelli et monsieur sur le podium
sionisme ce rapporteur général dans le
même esprit nous allons voter sans
contrainte
même si un rappel à notre règlement on
va voter le l'amendement du rapporteur
général qui élargit donc la baisse de la
tva à 5,5 à l'ensemble des dispositifs
de sécurité mais ce que vient de dire
alain richard il ya un moment nous avons
des divergences ici sur la construction
européenne
mais là y'a il ya le feu aussi en europe
aussi pour d'autres pays donc moi je
partage l'idée qu'on peut être aussi
incitatif ses accès et ça c'est le rôle
du sénat quand même c'est de se dire
voilà on est à la fois dans notre débat
franco français mais à la fois on est
sur un débat européen où est ce qu'il
faut pas pousser à la baisse de la tva
sur sur ce type de produits alors d'
immenses nécessités enfin je veux dire
j'ai plus impérieuse j'arrive plus à
trouver le terme vital nécessité donc
voilà si c'est pas le cas c'est pas le
cas on votera quand même foyer parce que
là on peut pas être dans des rancoeurs
et des amertumes le sujet trop sérieux
trop sérieux donc on va voter le la
proposition du rapporteur général
mais est-ce qu'on n'a pas cinq minutes
voyez pas c'est pas perdre du temps de
se dire est-ce qu'on pousse pas la
france à une baisse de la tva sur tous
les équipements de sécurisation des
populations des salariés de tout le
monde voilà là je trouve qu'à une valeur
d'égalité et qui tire un peu l'europe du
marasme dans lequel elle est aujourd'hui
quand même sur ces sujets là merci chers
collègues marc delattre
oui nous sommes dans le même état
d'esprit au rdse nous voterons sans état
d'âme l'amendement du rapporteur
simplement nous souhaiterions que cette
condition rappelé par le ministre
richard puissent être exposés
je pense que à l'europe je pense que
nous sommes là tous les pays européens
et tous les pays du monde entier dans la
même problématique donc l'europe
comprendra bien et sera même pour
certains pays demanderesse de cette
harmonisation et donc je pense
qu'effectivement nous votre ans en état
d'âme si nous avons
sur ans que cette démarche va être
conduite par le gouvernement sur cet
abaissement de la tva à 2,1 pour cent
merci merci monsieur la manie pour
explication de vote
oui merci président très rapidement sur
le mini char collègues simplement pour
me rallier à cet amendement du
rapporteur général qui fait consensus
par rapport et je crois que tous les
amendements sont particulièrement
importants et nombreux et le cas est
aussi j'irai la situation est aussi
exceptionnel et c'est vrai que en loi de
finances de rectificative et dans le
cadre de de ces amendements le la baisse
à au taux de 5,5 à une mesure réellement
importante et qui sera jaequi qui est
une mesure de justice ou s'il faut le
dire justice sociale et surtout
préserver la santé de tout est to say il
faut reconnaître que laisser ses
équipements aussi malheureusement manque
encore cruellement et certains collègues
on dit aussi que tous les matins
matériels sont souvent aussi viennent de
l'importation et on ne peut que
regretter
et ça ça date pas d'aujourd'hui c'est au
fil des années que des entreprises qui
les réalisent even leur ne les réalise
plus haut en france et faudra aussi à
terme se poser aussi les bonnes
questions en matière pour le monde
économique est leur priorité à la santé
je crois que et je me rallierai
naturellement à cet amendement
chers collègues monsieur la porter je
viendrai ce que disait notre collègue
alain richard mais l'honnêteté me
conduit à dire que nous sommes déjà sur
une interprétation assez large la notion
de produits médicaux parce que deux sur
les taux à 5,5 sur disputé médicaux de
condé sur aisne interprétation pour
rajouter lettonie protection on a une
interprétation ap extensive déjà donc la
première chose
deuxièmement j'entends bien tout ce
qu'on dit on plutôt souscrire chemin que
sinon on serait tous a souhaité soit une
exonération soit taux de tva à 2,1 sur
ces matériels qui sont vidés vraiment
des moyens de
première nécessité je vous rappelle
simplement que la règle en matière de
tva sur devait changer les règles c'est
la règle de l'unanimité en europe et
même sur la proposition de la commission
européenne qui propose de donner plus de
liberté aux états pour éventuellement
avoir des taux réduits pour avoir à
cette règle qui n'aurait plus de liberté
il faut alors elle même la règle de
l'unanimité
on n'y arrive pas donc alors je vois là
donc on peut toujours être dans le le
souhait on peut toujours vouloir tout
les choses voilà moi je ne sais pas
parler au nom de tous les pays de
l'europe et la règle de l'unanimité est
une règle qui est voilà qui est celle
qui est telle qu'elle est qu elle est
contraignante
donc je vous remercie de vos ralliement
l'amendement de 5,5
voilà on aurait souhaité faire plus
c'est aujourd'hui en l'état actuel du
droit de son attaque d'urgence la seule
solution opérationnels demain
si cet amendement est voté et s'il a
retenu ensuite à l'issue de la cmp
ça veut dire très concrètement que nous
aurons un taux de tva réduit sur
l'ensemble des tenues de protection et
c'est ce qu'on souhaite on aurait pu
souhaiter aller plus loin mais encore
une fois je vais pas engager un débat
sur la règle est limitée en europe qui
ne dépasse assister merci monsieur
rapporteur monsieur le président
retailleau monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre nous avons nous
allons voter plutôt que deux fois qu'une
l'amendement du rapporteur général pour
deux raisons la première parce qu'il est
complémentaire de ce que nous avons voté
hier soir en demandant à ce que les
achats par les collectivités de masques
soit remboursé soit au titre de la
section d'investissement par love cet
hiver
la deuxième raison la seconde raison est
là encore plus fondamental c'est que en
alignant le taux de tva sur le masque
sur des produits qui en général sont
remboursés par la sécurité sociale
nous voulons prendre position pour dire
aux français et pour dire aussi au
gouvernement que le masque est une
mesure efficace de protection
quand on a entendu dimanche la
conférence de presse quand on a entendu
que on nous disait lors d'une conférence
de presse qui avait pas un consensus
politique sur le point de savoir si le
masque est une protection ou pas on
s'est dit que les diafoirus
n'appartiennent pas seulement au temps
de molière qu'ils sévissent toujours
aujourd'hui au 21ème siècle en france
comment voulez vous que les français
comprennent que on ne tranche pas cette
question alors que il voit le président
de république à chaque sortie de terrain
désormais masqué avec un max non pas
chirurgicale mais ffp2 de haute
technologie comment les français
peuvent-ils dans la même conférence de
presse
encaisser cette affirmation qui indices
en sus scientifique autour de la
question de savoir si le masque est une
protection et ou pas alors que dans la
même conférence de presse
on leur dit que demain au moment du des
confirmands le masque serait rendue
obligatoire dans les transports voilà
l'autre raison pour lequel on tient à ce
qu'il y ait cet alignement et ce message
via la tva très clair pour nos
compatriotes
merci monsieur le président biz m
monsieur le président monsieur le
rapporteur monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues juste je voudrais
absolument confirmé l'intégralité des
propos tenus par le rapporteur général
j'aurais souhaité si je puis dire que
monsieur le ministre richard et raison
en la matière mais dès qu'on touche à
cette tva excusez moi d'être un petit
peu rigoriste en matière je dirais
européenne
c'est extrêmement compliqué c'est la
règle de l'unanimité
avant je dirais d'aborder ce sujet or je
vois mal que l'on puisse obtenir gain de
cause sur ce sujet précis je n'ai pas
prêt je dirais part au débat sur la tva
sur les centres équestres
mais bon c'est un sujet que que l'on
suit déjà depuis un certain nombre
d'années on a beau avoir des états tels
que l'irlande avec un taux de tva sur ce
sujet précis à 9% en france si vous
voulez ce sont des exceptions
donc personnellement moi je n'irai pas
plus loin ce que je peux vous dire c'est
que notre dernier entretien avec notre
ambassadeur représentant permanent à
bruxelles monsieur l'église costa ne
nous laissait peu d'espoir en la matière
je veux bien prendre l'engagement avant
la fin de ce débat de le rappeler dans
la journée pour avoir confirmation
mais on en reste là je pense aux jeux on
peut pas aller plus loin
merci donc je mets aux voix l'amendement
204 qui a été demandée en priorité
l'amendement de la commission
avec un avis défavorable du gouvernement
qui et pour qui et contre qui s'abstient
il est adopté et l'article est ainsi
rédigé donc les autres amendements et
cinq amendements identiques il 236 tombe
donc l'article 1er terre est adoptée est
ainsi rédigé donc tout passion à
l'article 1er quater avec deux
amendements identiques
le premier monsieur bargeton le dise
merci monsieur le président rapidement
c'est un amendement pour tenir compte du
fait qu'il ya certains types de gilles
hydro alcoolique qui ne sont pas
exactement hydro alcoolique mais qui ont
les mêmes prix propriété
nous avons été alertés par des
entreprises qui se situe sur divers
territoires de la france pour nous dire
que il produisait dégel qui était qui
respectait toutes les conditions
sanitaires qui était homologuée etc mais
qui du coup si on l'écrivait simplement
hydro alcooliques ne rentrait pas dans
la catégorie de cette tva donc c'est
pour cela que nous avons déposé cet
amendement qui permet de les comprendre
dans ce dispositif
merci beaucoup merci monsieur le
rapporteur d'amendements la commission
identique le 205 moment la commission
qui reprend ce qui était dit julien
bargeton c'était à l'ensemble des jeunes
et des produits gd n'affectant pas
simplement les gels hydroalcooliques
choix que d'ailleurs on a eu des
échanges en amont avec le gouvernement
je ne m'en cache pas sur les restes et
rédaction et donc c'est d'amendements la
maman de la commission s'était voter
couvrirait le champ de l'amendement de
julien bargeton et des autres
amendements qui suivent le 87 et le 237
donc aurait un taux de tva réduit
non seulement les jeunes mais les autres
produits qui peuvent y être assimilés ne
soit jamais reçu donc ça couvrait aussi
des produits biocides merci monsieur le
ministre avait favorable donc jamais on
voit les deux amendements a dit attirer
le gage monsieur le ministre
oui les gars j'ai retiré monsieur
savoldelli pour explication de vote
oui merci monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre ce directeur général ça
m'évitera d'intervenir sur les autres
sujets juste un petit éclairage très
concrets sur ce qu'on vient de décider
qui est important en val de marne avant
l'annoncé des cinq 5 la tva était à 20%
sur les masque en tissu
le chiffre de la tva pour des bons
département pour qu'il y ait un million
cinq cent mille personnes qui est un
masque réutilisables ces 4 114 mille
euros de tva pour les autres commandes
ffp2 et chirurgicaux dont nous sommes
acquittées on est à 193 1200 euros de
tva d'employer un département là la
petite couronne où on a pris cette
décision pour protéger nos populations
on avait avant l'assemblée nationale et
nos débats au sénat
six cent sept mille 200 euros de tva
pour l'instant dans les commandes faites
et croyez moi qu'on va maintenir le cap
sans argent compter pour qu'après le 11
mai on commande encore des masques et
des moyens de protection
donc c'est très concret et très
important les débats que nous avons eus
et précédemment et ce que nous avons là
merci madame la présidente prima pour
explication de vote existants simplement
une question au rapporteur au ministre
par rapport à sa précision et
l'amendement qui était portée par
monsieur grémillet monsieur grémillet
avait une précision dans son amendement
qui prenait en compte les produits de
désinfection des mains qui rentrait dans
la catégorie tp1 alors c'est un peu
c'est un peu technique mais ça du coup
ça exclut les produits cosmétiques par
exemple et en fait ça c'est par bien les
produits cosmétiques des produits
désinfectants
donc est ce que c'est une précision qui
mérite pendant la cnp d'être donné voilà
je pense qu'il faut regarder ce petit
point technique que monsieur grémillet
euh soulever merci monsieur le ministre
merci monsieur le président c'est un
point que nous nous regarderons
effectivement pouvoir s'il ya matière à
examiner cela je saisis l'occasion de
ces le président pour faire écho à ce
qu'il vient de dire le sénateur
salvodelli sur la question de la tva
applicable aux équipements la majorité à
l'assemblée nationale par la voie du
rapporteur général laurent saint martin
est à l'initiative
et il faut lui rendre cette initiative
de la baisse de la tva sur les masques
avec un accord du gouvernement
nous avons par la suite élargi cette
baisse de tva au gel désormais appeler
différemment pour être plus précis à
l'initiative d'amendements issus de
groupes minoritaires ou d'opposition de
l'assemblée aujourd'hui vous avez adopté
un amendement sur d'autres types
d'équipements que je ne sais pas évalué
d'un point de vue financier à l'instant
où je vous parle
mais je crois que ça démontre la volonté
d'une co construction par tous d'une
meilleure mesure de protection pour les
scénarii merci monsieur le ministre donc
je mets aux voix les deux amendements
identiques 10 et 205 donc je vis de la
commission le 205 avec un avis favorable
du gouvernement qui et pour qui et
contre qui s'abstient ils sont adoptés
et donc l'article 1er quater est ainsi
rédigé et ils font tomber les deux
amendements 87 et 237 donc nous passons
après l'article 1er quater à
l'amendement 69,9 delattre merci en fait
il est en lien avec l'amendement que
j'avais présenté hier soir je sais pas
pourquoi ils se retrouvent là parce que
c'était un amendement de repli de la
demande de baisse de tva sur les
produits viticoles en
en vente dans les restaurants cafés et
bars à 5,5
là c'est une proposition c'est
certainement parce que ce n'est pas le
même code le même article sur le code
général des impôts mais en fait il
s'agit d'une demande de la baisse de la
tva en restauration pour les produits
viticoles à 10% je le rappeler hier soir
la filière viticole était au bord du
gouffre avant le qu'ovide taxe trump
incertitudes sur le break site et
marchés asiatiques déstabilisée
nous avons eu à faire face au co vide et
dernièrement nous avons encore été
touchées par les aléas climatiques
le gel il y à quelques temps dans le sud
est il ya quelques jours la grêle
notamment en dordogne et dans le
saint-émilionnais donc il nous faut
plusieurs mesures
c'est ainsi que certainement non se
présente cette part des petites rivières
que nous arriverons à faire un un fleuve
dead pour la pour la filière en grande
souffrance
donc hier le ministre darmanin nous
parler à cette occasion puisqu'il était
défavorable à cette baisse de la tva des
charges patronales donc je maintiens
cette demande de baisse tva à 10% comme
cela peut se faire d'ailleurs en corse
donc étendre ce dispositif à la
métropole est aussi monsieur le ministre
vous demander des précisions quant aux
propos tenus hier soir par le ministre
darmanin sur l'exonération des charges
patronales pouvez vous à cette occasion
nous en dire un peu plus merci chers
collègues de vous rallier massivement à
cet amendement
merci monsieur rapporteur ça se on en
aurait vraiment envie s'échapper de
l'atr vous le savez très bien la réponse
sera la même
et je ne méconnais pas les difficultés
de la filière je soulignais elles sont
bien sûr l'obligation de matières du
personnel les difficultés d'exportation
que vous évoquez les difficultés de la
filière viticole sont multiples la seule
difficulté
vous la connaissez la réponse c'est que
la directive tva interdit expressément
le taux réduit pour les boissons
alcoolisées donc c'est là pour le coup
ce serait aller frontalement à
l'encontre de la directive s'ouvre à un
contentieux devant la cour de justice de
l'union européenne et l'instant notre
collègue jean bizet rappelé la règle de
l'unanimité qui est assez évidemment
difficile à contourner donc voilà donc
c'est sur le fond je partage totalement
les préoccupations le l'état du droit me
produis demandé le retrait de cet
amendement car encore une fois ne
saurions contraire à la directive tva
merci monsieur ministre c'est le même
avis monsieur le président donc une
demande de retrait ou à défaut un avis
défavorable concernant des exonérations
éventuelle de cotisations patronales
notre objectif est double gérald
darmanin l'a rappelé nous concentrer sur
les cotisations patronales puisque le
dispositif de chômage partiel permet aux
entreprises d'être dispensé du paiement
des cotisations salariales pendant cette
période là et ensuite faire en sorte de
trouver un dispositif qui soit conforme
au droit communautaire
nous ne pouvons pas automatiquement
accorder des annulations de cotisation
aux entreprises qui auraient demandé les
repas il faut que nos critères soient
plus objectif que flash soit plus
spécifiques et qu'il puisse ainsi être
conforme au droit communautaire et à la
manière dont nous travaillons avec la
commission c'est la raison pour laquelle
nous continuons à travailler sur ce
point là cela a été évoqué cela
reviendra très certainement dans le
débat sur la problématique report ou
annulation
merci il est retiré où il est retiré un
amendement 69
nous passerons 228 mada président le
primat monsieur le président le secteur
du bâtiment vous le savez est très
touché en particulier les opérations de
rénovation énergétique et je propose cet
amendement qui a été écrit par la
cellule de veille de crise et
d'anticipation qui travaille justement
sur les entreprises alors les chantiers
qui sont conduits par les professionnels
de la rénovation énergétique sont sont à
l'arrêt malgré le guide des
préconisations pour toutes les raisons
on a parlé notre collègue fabien gay
tout à l'heure la profession est
confrontée et pénurie de main d'oeuvre
au doute et à des difficultés liées à
l'approvisionnement l'acheminement des
matériaux le conseil supérieur de la
construction et de l'efficacité
énergétique estime que 90% de ces
chantiers sont en suspens en la
rénovation énergétique constitue l'un
des piliers de la politique énergétique
et climatique
le secteur du bâtiment représentant 20%
de nos émissions nationales de gaz à
effet de serre il est indispensable de
promouvoir les opérations de rénovation
énergétique pour atteindre l'objectif de
neutralité carbone d'ici 2050
le législateur a d'ailleurs prévu que
cinq cent mille rénovation de logements
soient effectués chaque année dont la
moitié à l'attention des ménages
modestes dans le but de disposer d'un
parc aux normes bâtiment basse
consommation d'ici 2050
dans ce contexte l'amendement présent
suppose propose de suspendre pour une
durée de 6 mois donc c'est tout à fait
court dans le temps la condition
relative à l'état d'achèvement depuis
plus de deux ans des logements qui
encadrent l'application du taux réduit
de taxe sur la valeur ajoutée de 5,5
afférents aux travaux d'amélioration de
leurs qualités énergétiques
c'est une mesure d'urgence qui doit
permettre de répondre à la crise tout en
favorisant l'atteinte effective des
objectifs de notre politique énergétique
et climatique
merci chers collègues le rapporteur je
comprends la préoccupation là des sites
et d'encourager les travaux je vois pas
très bien le caractère opérationnel
parce que évidemment les travaux de
rénovation par définition c'est sur le
logement ancien à logements neufs il est
déjà à la norme
donc on suspend la condition de deux ans
je crois que le vrai sujet ça me paraît
être celui que vous signalez tout à
l'heure c'est à dire ça me paraît être
les conditions dans lesquelles les
chantiers peuvent reprendre
aujourd'hui c'est moi d'encouragement
fiscal dont on a besoin c'est tout
simplement d'avoir des conditions
sanitaires d'avoir éventuellement des
règles que vous a dit qu'à l'instant
clarifiée concernant leur viabilité des
entreprises parce qu'il ya beaucoup
d'entreprises qui souhaitait reprendre
mais qui ne peuvent pas soient pas des
difficultés d'approvisionnement
matériaux parfois soit pour des raisons
de conditions sanitaires soit pour des
questions de responsabilité des
entreprises
malgré la parution
du guide par le fils et le ps btp donc
je pense que c'est vrai ça la vraie la
vraie question c'est moins une question
fiscale et travaux de rénovation il y en
a des particuliers ou des logements qui
déciderait des travaux il y en avait
avant la crise sanitaire y en aura après
la crise sanitaire
les personnes qui souhaitent faire des
travaux il y en avait avant une heure
après je pense que le marché est
toujours là la vraie difficulté et c'est
plus un problème extra fiscale c'est
comment les chantiers peuvent reprendre
dans quelles conditions at on les moyens
de production ça revient toujours à nos
débats d'avant est-ce que la
responsabilité de l'entreprise peut être
mise en cause dès lors qu'elles ont bien
sûr mis en place les mesures de
protection
est-ce que la confiance est là de la
part des clients est ce que les
personnes acceptent d'avoir des ouvriers
des personnes extérieures qui viennent
sympa que le vrai sujet parce que là
j'ai peur que ça ne change rien les
travaux la date des travaux dont
certaines demandes de retrait le
dispositif fiscal me semble pas être
celui qui est aujourd'hui doté plus plus
actionner mais peut-être que le
garnement un avis différent images
ministre ainsi le président le
gouvernement et le même avis donc c'est
une demande de retrait pour les raisons
évoquées par monsieur le rapporteur donc
je ne fais pas plus long je partage
l'intégralité de ses propos merci madame
la présidente très bas je vais me
retirer mais je reviendrai mais nous
reviendrons avec daniel grémillet et les
autres sénateurs sur cet amendement lors
d'un projet de loi de finances qui
parlera de la relance parce qu'il s'agit
bien évidemment d'un site et pendant
cette période là de nouveaux travaux de
rénovation énergétique alors c'est là si
on est sur un plan sur l'urgence je veux
bien le retirer mais on reviendra avec
pour le plan de relance
merci donc il est retiré nos passions
l'article 1er qu'inquiets ce plein de
parole de monsieur basse par le
président je n'ai pas déposé
d'amendement concernant le secteur
maritime et le transport maritime est
une activité à forte intensité
capitalistique avec des charges fixes
élevés et la situation économique et
financière des compagnies s'aggrave de
semaine en semaine les acteurs
économiques nous ont fait part dans leur
donnant que je souhaite ici appuyé
monsieur le ministre
gel des redevances domaniales
exonération des taxes portuaires
paiement immédiat des indemnités
d'assurance pour les sinistres existant
dans l'existant avant la crise ces gels
de redevances ce sont les directeurs des
ports qui les accordent
or il n'y a actuellement aucune harmonie
entre les ports français
aucune harmonie il ya quelques porcs qui
ont donné un avis favorable
d'autres n'ont pas répondu il faudrait
une extension du dispositif
d'exonération de charges patronales
prévues par la loi et dans le cadre de
l'économie bleus notamment sur les
pilotages remorquage et lamanage
monsieur le ministre je sais pas si vous
m'écoutez dans ces ports intégration des
pertes financières résultant d'une
immobilisation des navires face aux
risques sanitaires et à la pandémie dans
la catégorie des risques de guerre une
intervention la caisse centrale de
réassurance de l'état enfin un moratoire
de 18 mois pour le remboursement des
dettes et des intérêts un moratoire de
six mois semble t'il a été annoncé mais
il n'est toujours pas en oeuvre une
prolongation du prêt garanti par l'état
jusqu'à l'été 2021 et une meilleure
prise en compte des spécificités du
secteur maritime pour la mesure de
chômage partiel car je vous rappelle que
pour un poste il faut deux marins donc
il y a une spécificité dans le même team
qu'on n'a pas forcément au niveau des
industries et puis enfin concernant les
entreprises qui représentent une
souveraineté nationale
je voudrais vous sensibiliser sur notre
grand armateur français que le troisième
armateur mondial 51 49
il y a eu des prêts chinois il faudra
faire particulièrement attention pour
attention pour que nous gardons la
souveraineté et nous gardions un grand
amateur français en france merci chers
collègues
donc je me revois l'article 1er
qu'inquiets ce qui est pour l'article
1er qui inquiète ce qui est contre qui
s'abstient il est adopté après cet
article amendement 70 madame delattre
oui c'est complémentaire pour la filière
viticole aux demandes que j'ai pu
formuler précédemment c'est vrai que
nous avons une grosse pression dans la
filière sur la trésorerie puisque la
commercialisation est pratiquement à
l'arrêt pour beaucoup d'entreprises
viticoles et les charges
elle continue puisqu'il faut tailler la
vigne enfin ça c'est fait mais
entretenir la vigne mêmes
même quand effectivement on a dû subir
du gel ou de la grêle il faut aller
jusqu'au bout et continuer à payer les
salaires viticole donc nous avons
regardé ce qu'il était possible sur les
ressorts qu'il était possible d'activer
il y a aujourd'hui une trésorerie qui
existe dans certaines exploitations qui
est la dpee c'est une déduction pour
épargne de précaution qui est fait
justement pour prévenir de certains
aléas climatiques et nous pensons qu'il
est parti sans dégarni en l'ensemble de
cette épargne pour précaution mais
qu'une partie de cette épargne pour être
réintégré en trésorerie tout en
bénéficiant de la défiscalisation ce qui
normalement n'est pas possible c'est ce
que nous avons voté dans le plf 2010 9
mai nous demandons dans le cadre de cet
état d'urgence de pouvoir sortir la
moitié de cette dpe en défiscalisant 6,7
dpe est attribuée au paiement des
salaires voilà donc
j'espère que nous arriverons à trouver
un modus vivendi sur cet amendement
encore une fois pour participer à ces
petites rivières pour ce grand fleuve
pour aider la filière viticole merci
merci cher collègue monsieur le rapport
voilà pour l'examen ce matin de ce
deuxième budget rectificatif dans
l'hémicycle du sénat
ce budget qui a été adoptée je vous le
rappelle vendredi dernier à l'assemblée
nationale et qui prévoit notamment ce
plan d'urgence de 110 milliards d'euros
ce deuxième plan d'urgence annoncé par
le gouvernement depuis le début du
confinement noter que a priori bien les
sénateurs donc modifier ce projet de loi
est donc il devrait y avoir une
commission mixte paritaire que les
sénateurs espèrent en tout cas
conclusive et qui devrait se tenir
demain dans l'hémicycle du sénat on se
retrouve tout à l'heure à 14h50 pour
réduire les questions d'actualité au
gouvernement qui se poursuivent
également chaque semaine au sénat à tout
à l'heure
[Musique]